Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wir wollen blicken auf die Europäischen Top-Ligen im Männerfußball. Da ist wieder so einiges passiert. Es gibt sogar eine Meister-Entscheidung. Reden wir jetzt gleich drüber in Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Das hier ist der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass mit unserem Blick auf die Europäischen Ligen. Die Ligatur ist mal wieder fällig. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf masterdome.social. Freue mich sehr, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und freue mich sehr auf meine Runde. Später hören wir noch Uli Hebel, aber jetzt begrüße ich bei mir Mario Rieker. Hallo Mario. Dann Alexi Menuge. Hallo Alexi.
Bonjour, à tous et tous.
Und Alex Truica ist auch hier. Hallo Alex. Sehr schön, dass ihr drei hier seid. Wir wollen gleich auf die verschiedenen Ligen blicken. Vorher möchte ich aber noch loswerden. Der Rasenfunk ist werbepayable und sponsorenfrei. Bitte unterstützt uns finanziell. Und eine ganz wichtige Ansage habe ich da noch zu machen. Wir haben ja schon mehrfach kommuniziert, dass unser altes Konto, das FIDOR-Konto, das noch auf das Rasenfunk einzuliehen lief, dass das nicht mehr benutzt wird für den Rasenfunk jetzt, dass ihr unbedingt eure Überweisungen ändern müsst. Das haben doch nicht alle getan, obwohl eigentlich jeder jetzt inzwischen mindestens eine 1-Cent-Überweisung mit der Bitte, das Konto umzustellen erhalten haben sollte. Denn jetzt wird es aber dringend. Denn dieses Konto gibt es noch 12 Tage, dann wird es abgeschaltet. Die Fidor-Bank macht nämlich dicht. Das wussten wir auch schon. Das war einer der Gründe, warum wir uns ein neues Konto geholt haben. Also jetzt wird es langsam eilig. Ich habe auch gesehen, es gibt auch einzelne von euch, die jetzt doppelt auf Fidor überweisen. Da habt ihr einfach dann die falsche Bankverbindung genommen. Also bitte guckt euch das mal an. Auf rasenfunk.de/kontoerfahrtihr, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Und alle, die jetzt sagen, Mensch, Fidor, da wäre ich so gern mit dabei gewesen. Ja, dann unterstützt uns gleich aufs neue Konto. rasenfunk.de/supportersclubhilft euch weiter. Danke für alle, die uns unterstützen. Jetzt schauen wir rein in unsere Ligen. Und ich habe ja schon angekündigt, dass wir einen Meister hier verkünden dürfen. Nicht so ganz überraschend, deswegen ja auch schon zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Und es wird jetzt auch nicht an den Menschen da draußen vorbeigegangen sein, Mario, dass Napoli Meister geworden ist. Denn das war eben, wenn auch mit Ansage, aber doch ein historisches Ereignis. Das erste Mal seit 33 Jahren.
Ja, Agurri und Complimenti, auch noch hier im Rasenfunk tatsächlich nach Napoli, die haben so lange drauf gewartet, da darf man sie auch wirklich einmal heute hier hochleben lassen. Sie haben sich ein bisschen geziert. Ich hatte fast das Vergnügen gehabt, sie zu Hause zum Meister zu machen. Da haben sie dann noch irgendwie kurz vor Schluss einen Ausgleich kassiert. Da waren sie auch teils im Stadion enttäuscht, als wären sie gerade abgestiegen. Das war lustig, was da für ein Druck drauf war. Und das habe ich auch von vielen Leuten gehört. Oh, das ist wieder so typisch, dass sich das nicht klappt. Und das ist uns nicht vergönnt. Aber im Endeffekt, dann unter der Woche in Udine war das. Man hat gedacht, das ist jetzt nicht wirklich so klamorös. Aber da waren auch irgendwie über 10.000 Auswärtsfans. Und die Freude war riesengroß. Und dann hat man sie auch noch mal im Spieltag danach hochleben lassen zu Hause. Obwohl es da noch nicht mal den Pokal gab, war eine Riesenveranstaltung im Armando Maradona. Und inklusive Musik-Acts jeder Spieler ist einzeln rausgekommen. Und so wie man das von der Meister-Freier kennt, nur eben noch ohne Schale. Aber das haben sie sich nicht nehmen lassen. Und irgendwie kann ich das auch verstehen, dass man das dann mal so zelebriert.
Ja, absolut. Aber jetzt mal ganz kurz. Also auf einer Skala von total Mist bis richtig beschissen. Wie doof war denn das, dass du da nicht die Meisterschaft dann verkünden durft? Das ging Salernitana auch noch.
Ach, im Endeffekt finde ich dann... Wir hatten ja gestern auch kurz Kontakt. Da habe ich mir dann jetzt im Nachhinein auch gedacht, es gibt noch viel Zeit und noch viele Jahre gehen ins Land. Und Carsten Fuß hat ja dann in Udinett das kommentiert. Und der hat ja als der letzte Meistertitel in Napoli gewonnen, wurde da studiert und gelebt. Und irgendwie hat sich dann ein Kreis geschlossen. Und dann kann ich das da auch gut gönnen, dass er das dann da machen durfte.
Ja, okay, das ist ein sehr, sehr guter Hinweis. Ich meine, das Sportliche haben wir ja schon immer mal wieder die Saison über eingeordnet. Und es war auch relativ früh dann zu sehen, dass es wirklich klappen würde in diesem Jahr. Das hat ja auch das Aussehen der Champions-League zum Beispiel ein bisschen einfacher gemacht. Wie würdest du denn jetzt auch mit Blick auf die Feierlichkeiten und auf alles, was drumherum passiert ist, das jetzt dann so in größeren Kontext einordnen? Und was bedeutet das für die Serie A, dass Napoli Meister geworden ist?
Wenn es nach dem Präsidenten de Laurentius geht, bedeutet das, dass sie jetzt erst richtig loslegen. Der hatte da nach dem Spiel in Udinek gleich irgendwie eine Kampfansage gestartet mit wir wollen jetzt Nexus, über Nexus und in drei Jahren auch Meister werden. Ehrlicherweise war auch er, der im Sommer gesagt hat, wir holen das Ding dieses Jahr, während ich sie irgendwie auf Platz 8 getippt hatte. Also bin gespannt, was man davon erwarten kann. Ehrlicherweise kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen, dass die viele ihrer Spieler an Bord behalten. Es gibt gerade so ein bisschen um den Trainer Spalletti und Präsident, da gab es eine Vertragsverlängerung, eine Verlängerungsoption, die dann aber nicht mehr, also nicht ultimativ mehr Geld für Spalletti bedeuten würde. Da geht es jetzt glaube ich in die Verhandlungen. Für die Serie A bedeutet das, dass sie auch in diesem Jahr unter Beweis gestellt hat, dass sie extrem ausgeglichen ist in der Spitze, was glaube ich viele Ligen nicht von sich behaupten können. Ich finde, das ist eine riesen Nummer und das hat auch großen Spaß gemacht, den zuzugucken und wird es dann auch in der nächsten Saison hoffentlich auch. Kannst du das konkretisieren, was du meinst? Mit was bedeutet das für die Liga?
Ja, genau im Grunde eigentlich das, was du jetzt zuletzt gesagt hast, mit der Ausgeglichenheit der Liga und das ist ja wirklich interessant. Also man kann das im Rasenfunk quasi nachhören. Wir haben genau die goldene Zeit jetzt erreicht der Serie A. Es geht los, dass ich mit Christian damals als Juwe gegen Barca im Champions League Finale stand, darüber geredet habe, wie das Juwe hinbekommen hat, so dominant zu werden. Und im Grunde, vielleicht lag es auch am Rasenfunk, haben wir es dann aufgebrochen. Und seitdem ist es eben, also man konnte dieser Liga beim Aufblühen zugucken. Das haben wir ja auch schon hier thematisiert, aber wenn man sich nochmal dann die Finalspiele anguckt, den Europäischen Pokalwettbewerb, wir werden später auch noch über das italienische Halbfinale da sprechen, wo du einfach Juwe und Roma in der Europa League, Florenz in der Europe Conference League im Halbfinale und eben Inter und Milan jetzt im Champions League Halbfinale. Das ist eine Entwicklung, die ist kein Zufall, dass das jetzt in diesem Jahr so gekommen ist. So hat sich über die Jahre aufgebaut.
Und ich glaube, wenn das vielleicht noch was bewirken könnte, ist es, dass es irgendwie an anderen Plätzen jetzt schon auch zeigt, dass man da auch wieder irgendwie mittelfristig, langfristig eine Disziplin an den Tag legen muss, um dann dann auch Mannschaften wie Napoli her zu werden. Also es gibt halt eben nicht mehr dieses Monopol, das ein, zwei Vereine inne hatten. Und ich glaube, deswegen könnte das eben für die nächsten Jahre bedeuten, dass es ganz genau so weitergeht. So organisatorisch gesehen, glaube ich, haben sie da noch Aufholbedarf. Ich denke, da haben wir auch im Zuge der Frankfurtsch-Partie drüber gesprochen. Das war jetzt rund um die Meister-Feierlichkeiten auch nicht großartig anders. Also dass da jetzt irgendwie nach Udine über 10.000 fahren und da dann irgendwie so zehn Polizisten vorm Gästeblock stehen. Fragwürdig, dass die Ultras von Udine vorher ein Statement öffentlich rausgeben, dass sie sagen, bei uns wird nicht gefeiert. Und da stehen dann gar keine Polizisten und die kommen noch auf den Platz. Und sagen mal, herzlichen Glückwunsch inklusive gezogener Gürtel. Das ist dann auch wie in der Old-School-Italien. Nicht, dass ich da irgendwie jetzt so Gewalt verharmlosen wollen würde, aber es hat auch hausgemacht das Problem. Was dann in Napoli abging, war ja auch einfach sagenhaft, dass ihr das dann auch gesehen habt, was denen das bedeutet. Ja und ehrlicherweise da auch alles friedlich und einfach nur große Freude, was mich da ein bisschen gestört hat. Und da habe ich dann im Nachgang auch mit Christian eben, den ihr alle von hier kennt, auch länger geredet, was echt ein bisschen nervig war, ist, dass an dem Tag der Meisterschaft ist eine Person in Napoli erschossen worden. Und das lief auch sogar über Agenturen. Und es war immer die Überschrift Toter bei Meisterfeier. Und das kann man jetzt sogar noch nach googeln. Es gibt diverse Blätter, die dann unten einen Halbsatz im Artikel ergänzt haben, dass es sich bei dem Toten um den Sohn eines Kamorabosses handelt. Die Überschrift Toter bei Meisterfeier ist dadurch halt, sie ist wirklich komplett falsch. Und es gibt ja inzwischen auch in vielen Internet-Browsern die Möglichkeit, sich Artikel übersetzen zu lassen und vielleicht auch die heimische Presse zu lesen. Dass sowas dann auch über Agenturen läuft, hat mich ehrlicherweise ein bisschen sauer gemacht, weil dann auch KollegInnen einen ansprechen, boah, hier in Italien da dann wieder einer erschossen worden, weil da hatte einer eine Knarre dabei. Nee, da hat halt eine Gruppe diesen Tag genutzt, um jemand um die Ecke zu bringen, im Schutzmantel dessen, dass die ganze Stadtkopf stand. Das macht aber die Headline Toter bei Meisterfeier eben nicht richtig. Und da werden dann auch tatsächlich Ressentiments bedient und Schubladen aufgemacht mit Italien, da hat wieder einer eine Knarre dabei gehabt und so.
Ja, sehr gut, dass du das an der Stelle noch mal eingeordnet hast. Also das ist der Meister in Italien. Jetzt wollen wir mit Alexis Menuge den Meister, den kommenden Meister in Frankreich so richtig hochleben lassen. Denn bei PSG läuft es fantastisch, Alexis. Da gibt es eigentlich kaum was zu berichten Außersportliches, oder würde dir was einfallen?
Man könnte glaube ich für jeden Monat dieser Saison ein Buch schreiben, also insgesamt zehn bis zwölf, was da alles passiert ist, wieder auf und neben dem Platz. Das ist einfach ein Ausnahmeverein, positiv und negativ betrachtet natürlich. Es wird uns weiter begleiten, dass dieser Verein einfach polarisiert. Und wenn es wirklich darauf ankommt, dass Jose Mourinho der neue Trainer werden sollte, dann haben wir jeden Tag Spaß in der nächsten Saison. Da gibt es 100 neue Bücher zu PSG 23.
Wie viele hast du schon angefangen?
Ich versuche erst mal zu wissen, ob ich es auf Deutsch oder Französisch schreibe. Dann lege ich los.
Simo Tamu muss das machen. Du musst den im Honigstein pullen, musst du, Alexi. Der hat doch damals sein Buch…
Der hat keine Zeit, der hat so viel zu tun.
Nee, aber der hat quasi auf Englisch und auf Deutsch das Buch über den Aufstieg der deutschen Nationalmannschaft geschrieben. Das möchte ich von dir auch, Alexi. Also ich plädiere sehr für Deutsch, weil mein Französisch ist zu schlecht. Aber gut, was ist jetzt so zuletzt los? Also wir haben mitbekommen, es läuft nicht mehr so bei PSG. Niederlagen gegen Lorient und dann eben jetzt ein großes Aufsehen rund um Lionel Messi.
Ja, es geht nicht darum, dass man Spiele verliert, aber wenn man die Bilanz bisher 23 zieht, dann hat PSG neun Pflichtspiele verloren. Das wird beherrscht übergreifen, das ist natürlich viel zu viel. Es gibt einfach zwei Gesichter, das ist ein bisschen wie bei den Bayern. Du hast PSG vor der WM und nach der WM. PSG vor der WM hatte keine einzige Niederlage eingesteckt. Auch da wird beherrscht übergreifend. Und nach der WM ging es nur noch bergunter. Das muss man aber nicht nur an die WM natürlich als Schuld nehmen oder als Ausrede. Und einer der Gesichter dieses Versagens, nicht nur diese Saison, auch letzte Saison, ist dann Falionel Messi. Man fragt sich nach zwei Jahren, warum hat er sich für PSG entschieden und warum hat sich PSG für ihn entschieden. Man kommt jetzt in drei Wochen zu Trennung. Er wird doch noch wohl das Trikot tragen dürfen. Schon am Samstag gegen Ajaxio. Man weiß ja, was passiert ist. Letzte Woche ist er nach Saudi-Arabien geflogen, ohne seinen Verein Bescheid zu geben. Dort ist der Tourismus-Botschafter. Er hat einen Dreh für 30 Millionen Euro. Er hatte schon in den letzten Wochen zwei Mal Saudi-Arabien abgesagt, kurzfristig, weil PSG jedes Mal einen Tag vor der geplanten Abreise ein Spiel verloren hat. Dementsprechend hat Trainer Christophe Galetier eine Trainingseinheit, die nicht ursprünglich geplant war, dort noch eingesetzt. Das war nach der Niederlage gegen Lorient wieder ein neuer Fall. Aber Messi meinte, dass er es gar nicht mitbekommen hat. Er ist also in den Fieger eingestiegen. Währenddessen waren die Spieler von PSG auf dem Trainingsplatz. Messi hat da gefällt und das hat schon für viel Kopfschütteln gesorgt, in der ganzen Mannschaft, im ganzen Verein. Zum ersten Mal seit immer, seit die Scheiße eingestiegen ist, vor zwölf Jahren, haben sie sich durchgegriffen und ein großer Name bestraft. Man kann jetzt natürlich streiten über die Art und Weise der Strafe. Eine Geldstrafe war ja von Nöten, sage ich mal, vielleicht sogar ein bisschen zu klein. Also zwei Wochen Gehaltsverzicht für Messi, 1,6 Millionen Netto circa. Aber dass man ihn für zwei Wochen sperrt, dass er an kein Spiel teilnehmen darf, keine Trainingseinheit und in der vielleicht wichtigsten Saisonphase, wo man den Titel noch nicht in der Tasche hat, darüber kann man natürlich streiten. Aber das Komische ist, nach einer Woche durfte Messi noch ins Training und jetzt wissen wir auch, warum. Weil juristisch haben sich die Anwälte von Messi schon erkundigt. Er durfte nicht so lange gesperrt werden. Hätte er nie mehr das Trikot von Messi tragen dürfen, dann wäre diese Geschichte noch vor dem Gericht entstanden. Dann hätte PSG womöglich nur ein paar Millionen Abfindungen an Messi-Zahlen müssen, obwohl sein Vertrag ausläuft und das wollte man bei PSG unbedingt vermeiden. Man hat auch dieses komische Video von Messi vor einer Woche, wo er sich entschuldigt hat, angenommen und positiv in Paris, sodass man ihn am letzten Montag zum Training wiedergesehen hat und sodass er bereits am Samstag wieder auf dem Rasen des Prinzenpaar gesehen wird. Aber so oder so ist das eine traurige Geschichte und ein Flop. Ihr könnt davon ausgehen, dass er bei jedem Ballkontakt bei Ajaxio heftig ausgepfiffen wird.
Ich glaube, da müssen wir gleich Alex auch noch ins Boot holen, denn da gibt es ja auch schon Gerüchte, wo könnte es jetzt dann hingehen für Messi. Aber eine Frage zum Hintergrund möchte ich dann doch noch stellen. Glaubst du, es ist Zufall, dass jetzt der von Katar geführte Verein zum ersten Mal ausgerechnet bei dem Spieler durchgreift, der sich für Saudi-Arabien engagiert? Also das Land, das ja unter anderem mit Blockaden Katar klein halten wollte. Eines der Gründe, warum Katar sich zu dieser Sportswashing-Strategie entschieden hat, die es jetzt unter anderem mit PSG durchzieht?
Das könnte ein Grund sein, aber ich glaube der Hauptgrund liegt darin, dass man sich schon eh entschieden hatte, dass man mit Messi nicht verlängert. Er hatte ja eine Option um eine weitere Saison. Man hat ja gesehen, dass es nicht klappt, dass Messi unglücklich ist in Paris, dass er sich eh nicht anpassen will. Und dass er auch von den Fans und auch Teile des Vereins abgelehnt wird. Und dass keine Fortsetzung dieser Zusammenarbeit keinen Sinn ergeben würde. Man hat auch gesehen, dass wenn man Messi nicht mehr auf dem Platz hat, gleichzeitig, was selten der Fall war, weil immer einer verletzt oder gesperrt oder keine Lust hatte oder noch in der Disco war, dann merkst du, wie instabil die Mannschaft ist. Du hast drei Spieler plus acht andere, die für diesen drei Ausnahmestürmer laufen sollen. Das kann nicht gut gehen. Das hat man ja in den zwei Jahren in der Champions League gesehen. Voll in der K.O.-Phase jetzt gegen Bayern und letzte Saison gegen Real Madrid. Und deswegen musste man dieses Trio davon, diese MNM, ja, auseinanderreißen und auf jeden Fall in dieser neuen Saison nicht mit den drei gehen. Es kann starten, es kann gut sein, dass nur noch einer übrig bleibt, nämlich Mbappé, weil man versucht mit aller Macht, Neymar auch zu verkaufen. Und der Brasilianer ist mittlerweile auch bereit, wohl den Verein zu verlassen. Aber die Scheiß, wie gesagt, zurück zu deiner Frage, haben gemerkt, es macht einfach keinen Sinn mit Messi. Messi weiß auch, dass er seine Karriere woanders beenden möchte. Und deswegen war es halt eine perfekte Gelegenheit für die Scheiß, da durchzugreifen, endlich mal auch Clare Cante zu zeigen, und dass kein Spieler über die Institution PSG, wenn es die überhaupt gibt, stehen darf. Und das war vielleicht ein Zeichen einer neuen Ära bei PSG, zumindest, wie man mit den Spielern umgehen will, weil sie so viele Freiheiten haben, so viel Macht wie Papé, wie Messi, Neymar, Verraty, Maramos und Co. Das darf in Zukunft nicht sein, wenn man vor allem die europäischen Ziele endlich mal erreichen möchte.
Ich habe eine ganz übergeordnete Frage, Alexi, bevor Max vielleicht noch Alex da reinholt. So als Außenstehender hatte ich das Gefühl, jetzt holst du Christoph Gaiquet, das ist jetzt mal nicht der große Trainername und das könnte doch irgendwie so ein Fit sein, der das alles mal unter einen Hut bekommt. Kann man ihm irgendeinen Vorwurf machen oder ist die Mannschaft einfach untrainierbar?
Ja, ich würde sagen fast sowohl als auch. Als ich erfahren habe vor einem Jahr, dass Gaiquet kommt und nicht Zidane, dann habe ich schon eine Woche gebraucht, um mich davon zu erholen. Natürlich ist er Meister geworden 2021 mit Lille, sehr schön und gut. Aber es war doch klar, dass er diese Kabine nicht in den Griff kriegen kann. Er hatte keine Erfahrung, er hatte bisher nur sechs Champions-League-Spiele auf dem Buckel als Bilanzfünftender lagen. Und dann schickst du ihn so ins kalte Wasser oder ins Eisbach sogar, weil es unfassbar ist, dass man so einen Trainer holt, der keine große Erfahrung hat, mit großen Spielern und international betrachtet. Der kaum Englisch spricht, ein bisschen Spanisch und das war es schon. Bei dieser internationalen Kabine musst du schon ein paar Sprachen beherrschen, was bei Thomas Tuchel der Fall war oder bei Una Emery oder Pochettino auch. Galtier hat zwar keine schlechte Arbeit geleistet in der Hinrunde, aber das war ja nicht schwer, denn vor allem die Topstars haben nur an die WM gedacht und haben sich dafür top vorbereitet, indem sie alles gegeben haben für ihren Verein, um da topfit anzukommen. In der Rückrunde hat man gesehen, dass bei ihm die Kompetenzen fehlen, dass bei jedem kleinen Problem, dass er den Pfaden verliert. Er hat sehr viele Kommunikationsfehler gemacht in seinen zahlreichen Pressekonferenzen, die ihm auch als Eigentor gegolten haben. Deswegen hat er keine Zukunft bei Peugeot. Es ist einfach zwei Nummern zu groß für Galtier. Ich bin mir sicher, dass er in Zukunft weiterhin auf Top-Niveau arbeiten kann, aber bei kleineren Vereinen und nicht bei PSG. Das war natürlich ein Casting-Problem oder ein Casting-Fehler der Verantwortlichen. Man sieht seine Bilanz. Er wird zwei Meister, aber mit vielen Niederlagen. Der Champions-Sieger hat die Mannschaft keinen Zentimeter weitergebracht. Auch im Pokal, muss man sagen, ein Wettbewerb, das man gewonnen hat zu gewinnen in den letzten Jahren, hat er auch schon im Achtelfinale gegen Erzrivale Marseille das Nachsehen gehabt. Und so muss man sagen, seine Bilanz ist negativ. Und deswegen wird man sich spätestens Anfang Juni, wenn die Saison in der Liga vorbei ist, von ihm trennen.
Okay, da war ich auch tatsächlich einfach naiv. Das macht ja alles Sinn, was du sagst. Ich dachte, das ist jetzt halt mal genau der andere Typ im Vergleich zu den Trainern davor. Vielleicht funktioniert das aber.
Das Problem, wenn ich das noch hinzufügen kann, und es ist gut auch, dass du mir darüber ansprichst, nicht die Scheiße am Galtier gewählt oder geholt im letzten Sommer, sondern der Sportdirektor, der kein Sportdirektor ist, weil er kein Geld von PSG kriegt, Luis Campos, also der Direktor auf Fußball sozusagen, aber er ist ja schon angestellt bei Celta Vigo. Also auch noch eine skurrile Geschichte. Und er hat Galtier geholt, weil dieses Duo ist ja zusammen Meister geworden in Lille. Und Campos wollte unbedingt Galtier. Und auch bei beiden übrigens gibt es mittlerweile Spannungen, sodass auch da eine Zusammenarbeit oder eine Fortsetzung keinen Sinn ergibt. Auch wenn man auch da nicht weiß, ob Campos nächste Saison immer noch bei PSG oder für PSG arbeitet. Und sehr schnell hat man in Dora gemeint, der Galtier hat einfach nicht das Niveau, das Nötige, um die Mannschaft weiterzuentwickeln. Und deswegen ist man schon eifrig dabei, seinen Nachfolger demnächst zu präsentieren.
Na, also, da ist einiges los bei PSG. Du hast recht, also natürlich hast du recht, mit dem Buch pro Monat. Aber jetzt muss ich endlich Alex fragen, wen wird dann Barca alles verkaufen oder welche Rechte könnte man noch verschärbern, dass man jetzt Messi wieder zurückholt?
Ja, das prüfen sie aktuell. Das ist das, was, glaube ich, hinter den Kulissen...
Muss Robert Lewandowski wieder zu den Bayern? Der Arme.
Der Arme muss, glaube ich, nicht weg. Ich glaube, er muss nicht wirklich um seine Position bangen, aber viele andere Spieler schon. Also da wird man wirklich sehr, sehr viel unternehmen oder man unternimmt schon viel und wälzt die Bücher und überlegt und sucht Sponsoren und keine Ahnung, welche Möglichkeiten es da alles gibt, um Messi dann irgendwie zu holen und zu registrieren. Bei Barca ist ja das große Problem, oder mit Blick auf die Personalien, Messi ist das große Problem der Salary Cap, also diese Gehaltsobergrenze, die er nur in der Liga hat, in den Europäischen Ligen. Und ja, da muss Barca einfach Geld sparen, oder Spieler loswerden, die große Gehälter kassieren, damit man unter dem Salary Cap, unter der Gehaltsobergrenze, die jede Saison festgelegt wird, da Neuzugänge registrieren kann. Messi ist natürlich der prominenteste Name, aber wir reden ja auch von anderen Neuzugängen, die natürlich geholt werden sollen und wollen. Und ja, da muss Barca einiges tun, um das realisieren zu können.
Es ist halt ganz schön schlecht, wenn du jetzt schon den kleinsten Kader der Liga hast, mit nur 22 Spielern. Also arg viele gibt es jetzt nicht mehr, die man von der Payroll nehmen kann.
Ja, einer ist quasi freiwillig von der Payroll gegangen oder geht. Das ist Sergio Busquets, der hört auf. Die Ikone, die Legende Barca hat gestern offiziell bekannt gegeben. Oder der Verein hat es offiziell bekannt gemacht, dass Busquets seinen auslaufenden Vertrag jetzt im Sommer nicht verlängern wird. Er wird zwar die Karriere nicht beenden, wird woanders weiterspielen, aber eben nicht bei Barca. Das ist sportlich, ich glaube auch menschlich, auch ikonisch natürlich ein riesiger Schlag für den Barcelonismus, für Barca, für den Verein, für die Fans, für Xavi Hernandez, der weiterhin große Stücke auf ihn hält. Aber er war diese Saison einer der Großverdiener. Und finanziell gesehen ist das auch mit Blick auf möglicherweise Messis Rückkehr oder eben Verstärkung generell gar nicht so schlecht, dass er geht, weil er wie gesagt ein Großverdiener war und man zumindest sein Gehalt sparen kann, sein ex orbitantes. Da wurde auch berichtet, dass Barca natürlich, also Barca wollte ihn halten und hat ihm natürlich eine Vertragsverlängerung angeboten, aber angeblich zu einem Drittel seines aktuellen Salers, was er auch schon aufzeigt. Das hat nicht zwingend sportliche Gründe. Also er ist nicht ja nicht so viel schlechter geworden, dass man ihm nur noch ein Drittel anbietet, sondern sie konnten ihm nicht mehr anbieten und wollten ihn halten, aber eben nur zu stark gekürzten Bezügen. Buskets hat sich aber entschieden, nicht zu verlängern. Wird jetzt gehen und immerhin, in Anführungszeichen, spart der Verein so Gelder.
Ich bin heute im Modus, mir diese Fragen zu stellen.
Bitte.
Ich muss vorwegschieben, bevor mir die Messi-Fans in die DMs leiden. Ich finde ihn überragend. Aber ihn jetzt zurückholen.
Absolut.
Das ist eine kurze Frage. Der wird 16 und 30 jetzt.
Und dafür musst du irgendwie rumbasteln.
Seit 2015 bei Barca komme ich in die Wir machen noch einen Film.
Es ist eine sehr, sehr knapp formulierte Frage, die kann man gar nicht so knapp beantworten. Sondern man muss eigentlich ausholen und in viele verschiedene Themen eintauchen. Weil das eine sehr, sehr komplexe Frage ist. Zum einen, naja, das Happy End war nicht da. Romantik ist ein Grund. Einfach, dass man sagt, der beste Spieler der Vereinsgeschichte, vielleicht der Welt, soll sein vernünftiges Ende haben. Soll sein selbst gewähltes Ende haben. Bei seinem Verein, das hatte er einfach nicht. Er wurde gegangen, auch aufgrund des Salary Caps, wollte nicht gehen, hat sich unter Tränen verabschiedet. Er soll also seine Karriere bei seinem Verein beenden oder zumindest seinen Abschied bekommen. Das ist der eine Grund. Der andere Grund ist, dass er grundsätzlich eine Ikone des Vereins ist, den man einfach gar nicht hätte abgeben wollen. Also da ist sozusagen noch eine Rechnung irgendwie offen, in dem Sinne, dass er da zum Verein unbedingt nochmal zurückkehren sollte, weil PSG einfach dieses Mismatch war, diese komische Laune der Natur, die gar nicht gepasst hat, die aus jeglicher Hinsicht falsch war im Nachhinein. Also auch aus PSG-Sicht hat der Alexi auch selbst angesprochen, das hat nicht gepasst, das hat keinen Sinn gemacht im Nachhinein. Messi war da zwei Jahre unglücklich. Jetzt beschimpfen ihn die Ultras. Also das hat gar nicht gestimmt und sollte man fast schon rückgängig machen, kann man nicht, aber man kann die Geschichte eben zumindest, das Ende der Geschichte nochmal neu schreiben. Und dann ist auch sportlich ein Grund, dass man sagt, er ist zwar schon 35, aber ein bisschen was hat er drauf. Hat man bei der WM, glaube ich, schon ganz gut gesehen. Die ist jetzt nicht so lange her, liebe Freunde. Das sind vier, fünf Monate her. Da waren wir uns, glaube ich, einig, dass er der beste Spieler der Welt war, bei der WM und gezeigt hat, wenn er motiviert ist, wenn er ein funktionierendes Team um sich herum hat, wenn er Leidenschaft zeigt, wenn er richtig Bock hat und eben die Mannschaft für ihn arbeitet, dann ist der Typ nicht ganz so schlecht, auch wenn er schon 35 ist. Also Barca macht sich da auf Hoffnungen, dass der Mannschaft wirklich noch was geben kann, sportlich. Ja, in der Champions League haben sie ohne ihn jetzt zwei Jahre nicht ganz so erfolgreich gespielt, blamables Gruppen aus jeweils. Also man sieht ja auch, dass sportlich, obwohl man ja in der einen Saison auch Lewandowski hatte, dass es sportlich doch ein bisschen Verbesserungsbedarf gibt. Und ja, da sind die Meinungen eben auch, dass er das durchaus noch leisten könnte. Also das ist auch eine Antwort, eine Teilantwort, der Antwort. Und dann ist es auch finanziell, glaube ich, zwar ein Risiko, ihn zurückzuholen, weil man weiß ja gar nicht, ob man ihn überhaupt zurückholen kann, ob man ihn registrieren kann, bezahlen kann. Aber sollte es möglich sein, ja, poliert er dein Image unglaublich auf, dann sorgt er für Sponsoren-Einnahmen, dann sorgt er für ein noch volleres Stadion, dann sorgt er für Hype im Verein, in der Stadt, etc., etc. Also Messi ist ja auch eine Marke für den Verein, die dem Verein einfach sehr, sehr gut tut, der noch mal keine guten, ja, keine gute Bilanz zuletzt hat. Nicht nur sportlich, Champions League aus, Europa League aus, blamabel, sondern da gab es ja auch ganz, ganz andere große Themen. Dieser Schiedsrichter-Skandal, jetzt ziehen sie um mit dem Stadion, sind nicht mehr im Camp Nou, sind im Olympiastadion. Also du hast ja auch marketingmäßig da immer wieder negativ Schlagzeilen geschrieben. Und auch da, ja, tut dir Messi einfach gut. Du hast dann wieder diese Ausstrahlung, die Messi dir bietet, etc., etc., etc. Also das Thema Messi und Barca ist ein ganz, ganz großes Komplexes.
Ja, die Frage war ja tatsächlich auch bewusst provokant gestellt. Und ich folge dir da ja auch sportlich tatsächlich. Es gibt ja, soll ja auch andere Champions League-Teilnehmer geben, die noch 37-Jährige haben, die performen können. So ist es ja nicht, keine Frage. Und den Romantik-Aspekt kann ich auch voll nachvollziehen. Und da eine Anschlussfrage, wenn es jetzt dann so ums Finanzielle geht, ist er einer, der, der könnte doch auch für Ume spielen. Oder für sehr wenig.
Ja, das geht ja offenbar bei Spielern dieser Art nicht. Die müssen immer noch mal mehr Geld verdienen.
Ja genau, und das ist dann mein Problem tatsächlich mit der Sache.
Ja, das könnte man so formulieren. Messi's Vater müsste das beantworten. Das müsste man ihm fragen, weil er handelt ja die Geschicke seines Sohnes und ist dafür alles verantwortlich. Und auch logischerweise dann für die etwaigen Gehälter oder Einnahmen. Also auch mit Blick auf Saudi-Arabien. Dieses komische, was ist er da Botschafter? Reisebotschafter oder irgendwie Außendienstler Saudi-Arabiens. Da könnte man auch fragen, du hast doch so viel verdient. Muss das denn unbedingt sein? Kann nur der Vater beantworten, warum man eben den Geldern, die da fließen, jeglicher Art, nicht ganz so abgeneigt ist, obwohl man schon so viel verdient hat, und warum man da unbedingt noch mal mehr haben müsste, muss. Schmeckt mir jetzt auch nicht so, aber ich kann dir zum Beispiel auch nicht sagen, weil das, glaube ich, Barca selbst nicht weiß, welches Angebot überhaupt auf dem Tisch liegt für Messi. Also sportlich zurückzukehren zu Barca, welches Jahressalär, weil Barca das noch nicht weiß, weil sie das einfach ausrechnen müssen. Sie müssen, nochmal, sie müssen Transfereinnahmen generieren, sie müssen spielerlos werden, sie müssen Gehälter cutten und dann können sie unter dem, dann errechnet La Liga, welcher Salary Cap möglich ist, welche Gehaltsobergrenzen, und dann können sie Messi sagen, du, schau mal, wir können dir, keine Ahnung, 10 Millionen per Annum anbieten oder 15 oder 20 oder 25. Das müssen sie erst rausfinden, sprich, ich kann dir da nicht mal die genaue Zahl nennen, weil die Barca wahrscheinlich selbst nicht nennen kann, was man ihm überhaupt anbieten kann, wie viel es ist. Also wenn du sagst, er sollte möglichst für Ume oder für sehr wenig spielen, kann sein, dass er das muss, kann sein, dass er das annimmt, das müssen wir einfach abwarten. Das kann man zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch nicht beantworten.
Ja, und vielleicht muss man da auch, also ja, dann sollen die Messi-Fans bei mir in die DMs rein sliden. Also ich kann mir nicht den Hinweis verkneifen, wir müssen aufhören, Leute, die etwas sportlich gut tun können, zu guten Menschen zu machen. Lionel Messi ist ein überführter Steuerstraftäter. Der hat 21 Monate Freiheitsstrafe bekommen. 21 Monate, die nur weil er Ersttäter war, zur Bewährung ausgesetzt wurden. Er hat Gelder seiner Stiftung abgezweigt auf irgendwelche Offshore-Konten. Das kann man alles bei den Football-Leaks nachlesen. Und klar kann man auch vielleicht sagen, vielleicht war da auch der böse Vater dran schuld. Er hat es aber immerhin zugelassen. Diese Menschen, die wir alle bewundern für das, was sie auf dem Platz tun, sollten wir vielleicht nicht für alles neben dem Platz bewundern. Vielleicht ist das dann auch Teil der Antwort auf diese Frage. Warum zum Beispiel dann auch ein bisschen weirder turnen. Aber bei Sergio Busquets habe ich mir das auch gedacht. Klar ist es keine Wertschätzung, wenn du ein gekürztes Gehalt angeboten bekommst. Auf der anderen Seite weißt du ja, was bei diesem Verein passiert. Auch da können wir davon ausgehen, Busquets wird nicht am Hungertuch nagen jetzt den Rest seines Lebens. Die leben ein anderes Leben als wir, Lionel Messi. Toller Fußballer, was er aber so neben dem Platz macht. Meine Güte!
Soll übrigens ein monströses Angebot aus Saudi-Arabien vorliegen haben.
Busquets, ne?
Ähnlich wie Ronaldo. Busquets auch, aber in dem Fall Messi. Busquets glaube ich auch. Ist das Al Hilal? Ich meine, die da versuchen ihn zu ködern, indem sie zum Beispiel Busquets seinem Kumpel, also Messi ist ja nach seinem Abgang nicht mehr mit jedem gut verblieben bei Barca. Zum Beispiel mit Piquet hat er sich verstritten. Die haben gar keinen Kontakt mehr, heißt es. Mit Tastegen war er sich nicht so super grün, dass die unbedingt privat befreundet waren, obwohl sie im gleichen Vorort leben. Aber mit Busquets und Alba ist er zum Beispiel sehr, sehr eng befreundet geblieben. Immer wenn er zurück nach Barcelona jettete, hat er sich mit denen zum Abendessen getroffen. Und da heißt es eben, dass ich meine, Al Hilal war es, Busquets versucht zu holen, damit man die Chancen erhöht, dass auch Kumpel Messi dann zum Verein kommt. Und natürlich mit den entsprechenden Geldern. Also mit Fabelsummen, die man gar nicht greifen kann.
Hunderte Millionen Euro. Ich habe etwas von 600 Millionen Euro gelesen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Hunderte, aber Hunderte.
Genau, eigentlich ist es dann schon scheißegal. Also eigentlich ist es dann wurscht, ob das 100 sind oder 600. Es ist einfach absurd viel. Und das kann er natürlich machen. Aber wir müssen jetzt nicht so tun, als ob Lionel Messi bisher immer alles dem Sport und der guten Tat untergeordnet hätte. Sondern genauso wie ganz viele andere in der Branche geht es da um Geld. Und erstmal auch nur um Geld.
Also was ich so höre, um das Geld-Thema so ein bisschen auslaufen zu lassen, dass seine Priorität ist, zum FC Barcelona zurückzukehren, vor allem weil seine Familie zurückkehren möchte, weil er jetzt einfach nicht glücklich war, nicht happy war in Paris. Und das inkludiert natürlich seine Familie mit seinen Kids und seiner Frau Antonella. Und die möchte natürlich zurück nach Barcelona, beziehungsweise nach Castel de Fels, wo sie leben. Das ist so ein kleiner Küstenvorort, sehr beschaulich, sehr schön. Da lebt auch Tastegen, da kann man glaube ich sehr, sehr gut leben. Und da sehen sie sich zurück, da wieder zu leben. Aber eben, ja, Thema Geld spielt halt einfach auch eine Rolle. Und in dem Fall sogar aus Vereinsseite, weil eben Barca nicht weiß, was sie ihnen anbieten können, oder ob sie ihnen überhaupt registrieren können. Also die klären das einfach. Und deswegen glaube ich, oder was ich so höre, ist seine erste Option Barca, aber eben wahrscheinlich nicht um jeden Preis, um jetzt doch wieder den Boden zu spannen.
Ich meine, das Gute ist ja, in Saudi-Arabien kannst du auch mit 39 gingen. Also da wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht diese Debatte geführt.
Also er will zum Beispiel die Karriere auch in der Nationalmannschaft noch nicht beenden, liest man so. Der WM-Titel war quasi noch nicht der Last Dance. Man könnte ja sagen, auf einen absoluten Höhepunkt kannst du gehen, aber irgendwie hat das noch mal ein bisschen Feuer in ihm entfacht. Offenbar berichten zufolge aus Argentinien, dass er wirklich noch die nächste Copa América, ich meine die ist 24, also gar nicht so lange hin, mitnehmen will, weil er auch einfach merkt, wie viel Spaß das gemacht hat, wie gut die Mannschaft ist. Dass er da immer noch die Schaffenskraft dazu hat, ist er offensichtlich. Und er denkt sogar offenbar über die nächste WM nach, dass er die noch spielt. Und da will er quasi competitive bleiben, auf einem höheren Wettbewerbsniveau spielen. Optimalerweise natürlich bei seinem Herzensverein schrägstrich in Europa. Und ja, anders als eben Cristiano Ronaldo, wo du merkst, wenn du jetzt nach Saudi-Arabien oder sei es China oder wo auch immer hin gehst, dann ist das wirklich quasi der Feierabend der Karriere und nur noch so ein bisschen Feierabend kicken. Und das will er offenbar nicht. Also er möchte noch wettbewerbsfähig spielen, aber eben nicht umsonst wahrscheinlich.
Okay, gut, machen wir das Messi-Thema zu. Wir bleiben aber dann gleich bei Barca, weil wir jetzt eh schon so lange über Barca reden. Denn da steht ja ein Statuell an am Wochenende. Und das könnte für beide Beteiligte, nämlich sowohl für Espanol als auch für Barca, große Konsequenzen haben. Für die einen erfreuliche, für die anderen nicht so erfreuliche, Alex.
Ja, Barca kann Meister werden am Wochenende. Wenn sie einfach gewinnen bei Espanol, sind sie Safe-Meister. Und wenn Real Madrid und Atletico vorher nicht gewinnen, ich glaube, die spielen nämlich beide vorher am Spieltag, dann wäre Barca auch ohne eigenen Siegmeister, weil sie einfach vor Atletico dem zweiten, ich glaube, 13 Punkte Vorsprung haben, bei noch fünf ausstehenden Spielen. Also da ist die Meisterschaft safe. Die Frage ist nur, jubeln sie ausgerechnet beim Stadterz-Rivalen, beim Verhassten. Wobei der Hass eher aus Espanols Richtung kommt und Barca eher so runterblickt auf den kleinen Stadtnachbarn. Aber ja, bei Espanol, Meister werden hat natürlich, hätte etwas ganz Besonderes, weil man sich eben gar nicht grün ist. Und aus Espanols Sicht wäre das richtig, richtig bitter. Nicht nur, weil es im eigenen Stadion bei Espanol ist, sondern weil die die Punkte dringend brauchen. Diesen 19. aktuell haben drei Punkte Rückstand auf die nicht-Abstiegs-Ränge. Also richtig, richtig in Abstiegsgefahr. Wenn die also verlieren, Barca Meister wird. Und du selber nicht nur im Abstiegskampf steckst, sondern dann mit, ich will nicht sagen, 1,5 Beinen in der zweiten Liga bist, aber halt immer tiefer da reinrutscht und es immer aussichtsloser wird.
Aber absolut. Kann man denn in wenigen Worten zusammenfassen, wie Espanol in diese Lage gekommen ist? Also dazu gehört, es ist noch relativ eng. Also innerhalb von vier Punkten liegen da so fünf Teams, die zwei Absteiger zusätzlich zur L-Challenge unter sich ausmachen. Aber wie ist Espanol da reingeraten?
Ja, indem sie einfach nicht erfolgreich genug Fußball spielen, ohne dass man sagen kann, woran das wirklich liegt. Also es ist nicht so, dass kein Mittelstürmer vorne der Tore schießt. Doch, den haben sie in Horselou, alter Bekannter aus der Bundesliga. Ist richtig gut unterwegs, hat schon zweistellig getroffen. Ist also so der Lebensretter fast schon. Also ohne seine Tore. Ich glaube, er hat 14 oder 15 schon, was für so einen kleinen Verein, der grundsätzlich wenig Tore schießt, sondern in dem er sehr, sehr gut der Ausbeute ist. Wenn man sich vorstellt, dass sie ihn nicht hätten, dann sehe es ja noch düsterer aus. Sie spielen einfach nicht so erfolgreichen Fußball, wie man sich das wünschen würde. Also wenn du fragst, woran liegt es bei, weiß ich nicht, Schalke oder Hertha? Na ja, du mühst dich ab und kämpfst und hast zwar den einen Torschützen vorne drin, aber ansonsten ist der Fußball halt leider sehr, sehr überschaubar. Woran das liegt, ja, das müssen der Sportdirektor, muss der Sportchef, muss der Manager beantworten. Das ist meistens irgendwo in der Kaderzusammensetzung zu finden. Aber so den einen Grund, warum es bei denen nicht läuft, ist schwer zu sagen. Man hatte tatsächlich, und auch ich bin da mit dem Boot nicht erwartet, dass sie so dermaßen tief im Abstiegskampf stecken würden. Also ich hätte eher gedacht, zwischen Platz 10 und 15, nur sicheres Fahrwasser, aber nee, dass sie so eine enttäuschende Saison spielen, ist tatsächlich einfach überraschend.
Aber wir wissen doch im Grunde, wie es laufen wird. Alex, es wird jetzt dieses Derby geben. Es steht ganz lange 0 zu 0. Und dann kommt der zweiterfolgreichste Torschütze hinter Roselu mit seinen 14 Toren, nämlich Martin Braithwaite. Und der wird dann das 1 zu 0 erzielen. Und dann wird es eine Geschichte geben, die nur der Fußball schreibt. Es muss einfach so kommen.
Das ist übrigens auch eine witzige Personalie, weil wir da doch wieder den Bogenspann zum Cellular-Cap, den hat Barca nämlich rausgeeckelt, rausgeworfen, wollten ihn loswerden. Er wollte partout nicht gehen, hatte ja noch laufenden Vertrag. Und dann haben sie ihn rausgekauft aus dem Vertrag, damit sie ihn loswerden. Und er wollte keinesfalls irgendwo hin. Und hat halt so lange darauf gepocht, dass ihn Barca rauskauft, damit er auch in der Stadt leben kann und ist zu Espanyol gegangen. Aber quasi wurde bezahlt dafür, dass er den Verein verlässt. Also man hat sich hinter den Kulissen irgendwie geeinigt. Ja, auch da wieder Thema Cellular-Cap. Barca wollte unbedingt sein Gehalt sparen, aber er wollte Partou nicht weg. Deswegen wäre das wirklich eine runde Geschichte, weil er eben auch gut sportlich funktioniert, weil er auch bei Barca nichts zu suchen hatte, sportlich, wenn man ehrlich ist. Das hat ja diese anderen Hintergründe, dass sich ja alle Stürmer schwer verletzten bei Barca damals. Aber ja, das wäre wirklich eine amüsante Geschichte.
Es wird genauso kommen. Eine andere Möglichkeit sehe ich jetzt gar nicht mehr. Aber jetzt hatten wir irgendwie gefühlt eine halbe Stunde Barca-Talk. Wir haben ja noch ein paar andere Ligen, über die wir auch noch sprechen wollen. Lasst uns doch mal über das reden, was wir da am gestrigen Abend beobachten konnten. Mario, damit bist du wieder Herr dieser Runde. Denn Milan gegen Inter haben das erste Halbfinale in der Champions League untereinander ausgespielt. Und es lief sehr gut, unter anderem für den 37-Jährigen, den du vorhin schon angesprochen hast. Edin Dzeko in der 8. Minute mit dem 1 zu 0 nach einer Ecke und Mkhitaryan in der 11. Minute mit dem 2 zu 0. Also es ging sehr, sehr erfolgreich für Inter los. Und Milan konnte darauf nicht mehr so richtig reagieren. Hatte eigentlich, würde ich sagen, sogar noch Glück, dass Menor da noch Schlimmeres verhindert hat. Es wurde ein Strafschuss zurückgenommen und er hat sehr gut gehalten. Warum war Milan so deutlich unterlegen? Oder waren sie es gar nicht so sehr?
Lustig, dass du gerade Dzeko genannt hast. Der ist ja auch 37. Ich war gerade vorhin bei Modric.
Ich hab Modric gemeint tatsächlich.
Ich wusste übrigens, dass du Modric meinst.
Ich fand es nicht so überraschend, dass Inter besser ist. Ich hatte die da schon auch tatsächlich vorne insgesamt, weil sie gerade in einer Phase der Saison sind, wo Insagis geschafft hat, diese Mannschaft so krass auf diese KO-Duelle einzustellen. Also die Einsagen-Pokalmannschaft. Ich zitiere ihn jetzt, glaube ich, diese Woche zum vierten oder fünften Mal. Der Kollege Thomas Hirner von der Süddeutschen Zeitung hat mal bei uns im Podcast den, finde ich, so passenden Begriff geprägt, gerade für Inter. Es ist so eine Gegenwartsmannschaft. Und er hat selber sich eigentlich über Dzeko aufgeregt, der ja unfassbar viel Geld verdient und auch dadurch teilweise Transfers blockiert hat. Aber da ist er zur Stelle in so einer Partie. Und Inter hat qualitativ in der Breite den besseren Kader. Und Milan hat halt 12, 13 Spieler für die erste 11. Und dann muss alles funktionieren. Und du hast ihn gestern schon deutlich angemerkt, dass das den auch irgendwie im Kopf was veranstaltet hat, dass dann eben Leão, der die letzten Wochen so aufgeblüht ist wieder, der auch eine schwere Phase nach dem Winterturnier hatte. Und dann fällt der auf einmal aus und nimmt dir so viele Möglichkeiten in Sachen Tempo, Ideen, Einzelaktionen. Sie haben ja auch trotzdem versucht, so viel über links zu machen, wo auch Theo ja ein Faktor ist. Aber Salamakas, so gut er auch ist, und der ist ja teilweise auch in der Startelf gestanden, aber auf der anderen Seite gemeinsam mit Leão, der dann Leute links bindet. Und das hat bei Milan überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Und ich muss dazu sagen, dass die genau wie Benfica in der Runde davor mit den ersten 15, 20 Minuten von Inter völlig überfordert waren. Also ich finde, das war ganz extrem, wie sie nichts entgegenzusetzen hatten, obwohl sie ja zum Beispiel davor Napoli auch defensiv so entzaubert haben, dass sie da so viele Räume gegeben haben. Auch ich finde, das Mkhitaryan-Tor, das ist natürlich auf der einen Seite toll rausgespielt. Auf der anderen wusste, also ich meine, Kehr weiß jetzt immer noch nicht eigentlich, wo er hätte stehen sollen, genauso wie Tomori. Und dann ist das tatsächlich ein Spielverlauf, der, sagt man ja so schön, Inter komplett in die Karten spielt. Weil Insagi war auch schon bei Lazio als Trainer bekannt, der irgendwie kompakt stehen kann und dann kontern kann. Und die Inter mit der Aggressivität, die auch bestimmte Spieler an den Tag gelegt haben. Du hast mir so ein paar schöne Stats geschickt. Und ich finde, der eine Screenshot mit den Spielern out of possession, laut Taro möchte ich hervorheben, ist unfassbar, vom eigenen Strafraum bis zum anderen Strafraum. Der, der überall Zweikämpfe führt, der hat ja auch so sein kleines Tief, aber jetzt ist er seit einem halben Jahr auch noch Weltmeister. Und knipst jetzt wieder. Aber was der auch gegen den Ball veranstaltet, ist unfassbar. Und ehrlicherweise, du hast es schon gesagt, ich finde, Milan hat mit dem Ergebnis tatsächlich sogar noch ein halbwegs ordentliches für sich selber mitgenommen. Ich verstehe auch ehrlicherweise nicht, warum es da mit der Ende zweiter Halbzeit keinen Elfmeter gibt, weil es Krunic sich zu dieser Dummheit hinreißen lässt, wo er schlägt. Sepp Kneisel war der Meinung, das reicht nicht für einen Elfer. Ich sage schon allein, weil er so dumm ist, da im Strafraum zum Schlag auszuholen, das ist ja kein Schieben. Also da habe ich mir dann wieder gedacht, na gut, die UEFA will halt irgendwie keinen 0-3 haben. Aus Spannungssicht. Aber ich fange jetzt nicht mit den Verschwörungstheorien hier an. Aber hinter ist gerade, fehlt eigentlich nur Gosens und Skrinha. Und ansonsten haben die einen Kader beisammen, der qualitativ wirklich hochwertig ist. Und ehrlicherweise, glaube ich, gegen Real oder City dann auch sehr viel mehr Möglichkeiten hätte, als Milan dann noch im Finale irgendwas zu bewegen, wo alle dann natürlich irgendwie entweder Real oder City auf ihren Favoriten zerklagen werden.
Ich meine, es gab noch den Pfostenschuss von Tonali, der ja auch noch leicht abgefälscht war. Das war ein gutes Ding. Es gab allerdings auch noch den Pfostentreffer von Shala Nulu. Also es war insgesamt ein sehr gut anzusehendes Spiel, muss ich sagen. Also genau das, was man sich erhofft hatte. Kannst du verstehen, dass Pioli auf diese Anfangsphase nicht reagiert hat? Er musste Benazir früh rausnehmen wegen Verletzungen. Aber wir haben ja schon mal hier an dieser Stelle darüber gesprochen, dass es mal eine Umstellung auf Dreierkette gab, die sehr geholfen hat. Und gleichzeitig hätte man damit auch so gewisse Probleme, die Inter einem einfach bietet, weil sie eben viel über die Flügel kommen und dann in den Halbraum rein spielen, hätte man adressieren können. Als ich gesehen habe, da gibt es jetzt eine Auswechslung. Ich konnte da nur nicht gleich erkennen, wer sich fertig macht. Da dachte ich mir, okay, er bringt Ciao und stellt halt wirklich auf Dreierkette um. Weil das wäre so mein erster Gedanke gewesen. Wurde das thematisiert jetzt im Nachgang?
Pioli war auf jeden Fall Thema im Nachgang, wie die letzten Wochen auch schon. Das ist ja das Spannende, dass beide Trainer extrem unter Druck standen. Also bei Insagi, glaube ich, habe ich selber auch gesagt, und Christian, wobei Christian ist eher der Fürsprecher für die Trainer, weil sie tatsächlich ja schon immer noch eine erfolgreiche Saison spielen. Aber die Ansprüche sind bei beiden Mannschaften gewachsen. Und Pioli wurde immer so ein wenig vorgeworfen, dass er nicht auf schlechte Phasen reagieren kann. Ich finde, dieses Jahr hat er es eigentlich bewiesen, dass er es kann. Die von dir angesprochene Umstellung, die er auch zwischenzeitlich in der Saison hat, Dreierkette, dann wieder Viererkette, da hat er selber mal aktiv gecoacht. Gestern bin ich der Meinung, vollkommen bei dir, da hat ihm der Mut oder die Erkenntnis in dieser Situation gefehlt, da auch wirklich zu handeln und der Mannschaft von der Seitenlinie irgendetwas zu geben, das den Spielern auf dem Platz hilft. Ich kann es insofern verstehen, dass er dann irgendwie nicht noch mehr Unruhe reinbringen will. Ich habe vor ein, zwei Wochen ein Interview mit Angelotti gelesen, der schon weiß Gott so viel erlebt hat als Trainer. Er war ja damals bei den letzten Aufeinandertreffen Anfang, Mitte der Nullerjahre Milan Trainer. Er hat gesagt, bis heute hat er eigentlich noch nicht ein einziges Mal diesen Druck verspürt und diese Ohnmacht. Wenn er jedes Mal aus der Kabine rausgeht, muss er eigentlich das Kotzen unterdrücken, weil da so viel auf dem Spiel steht. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass da eventuell Pioli nicht den klarsten Kopf hatte und eventuell auch genau wie seine Mannschaft völlig überfordert war.
Ja, oder eben genau das. Ich finde das schon gut, auf diesen Druck hinzuweisen, unter dem alle Beteiligten stehen. Und das kann ja auch selbst, wenn Pioli frei gewesen wäre von diesem Druck, könnte er aber aus guten Gründen dann sagen, jetzt nicht noch eine systemische Umstellung hier reinbringen. Weil man hatte ja viel Beibesitz und Inter hat dann auch relativ früh angezeigt, nach dem 2-0, jetzt zieht man sich eher zurück und setzt auf die Konter. Also sprich, Milan hat jetzt nicht auch, also es sah jetzt nicht so aus, als würde Inter einfach so weiter rollen. Es war halt klar, die kriegen ein paar Konter. Das wird auf jeden Fall passieren, ist ja auch dann passiert. Aber vielleicht war das auch ein Grund. Und dann ist es vielleicht auch der typische Unterschied von, wir sehen es halt irgendwie von unserem Sofa aus, oder du natürlich aus den The Zone Headquarters heraus. Und im Stadion ist es aber nochmal was anderes.
Was ich tatsächlich aus Milan, was ich mit dieser Ausgangssituation fürs Rückspiel besorgniserregend wahrgenommen habe, ist, dass sie selber aus ihrem Ballbesitz überhaupt keine Tiefe erschaffen haben. Also Chirou hing ja völlig in der Luft. Der war in den letzten Wochen auch nicht immer der perfekte Zielspieler. Aber dass sie das auch gar nicht großartig versucht bzw. geschafft haben, ihn da vorne irgendwie einzusetzen, einen Ball festzumachen und dann irgendwie gesammelt nachzurücken, war schon wenig. Oder halt sehr gut und diszipliniert verteidigt von Inter. Kann man so oder so sehen. Ich weiß nicht, wie siehst du es?
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich habe mich in Asabi so ein bisschen verliebt. Also nicht alles, was er auf dem Platz gemacht hat, fand ich gut. Weil in meinem Ideal sind das alle faire Sportsmänner und da wird niemals eine sogenannte Nicklichkeit ausgetauscht. Und es war ein an Nicklichkeiten nicht armes Spiel, ohne dass es unfair gewesen wäre. Aber ich fand, dass Asabi genau den richtigen Mittelweg gefunden hat. Und es gab ja die eine Szene, wo Giroud im Abseits angespielt wurde und dann stecken wollte auf Dias. Und der wurde einfach von Asabi abgelaufen und hat ihn dann aber so am Schluss noch geschubst. Und dann gab es halt dieses typische Kopf an Kopf, beziehungsweise eher Kopf am Brust bei den beiden. Und in dem Moment habe ich gedacht, von Ibrahim Dias werden wir nichts mehr sehen in dem Spiel. Der ist so klar als Verlierer aus dieser Szene rausgegangen. Das war krass und das stand für mich symbolisch für dieses Spiel.
Ja, Asabi hat auf jeden Fall auch so die spitzen Ellenbogen, die Bonucci und Chiellini immer hatten. Ich glaube, es ist super unangenehm, gegen ihn zu spielen. Aber er ist auch lustigerweise einer, der oft von außen auch kritisiert wurde, bzw. sein Wechsel zu hinter wurde kritisiert, weil es auch so ein Insagi-Spieler ist. Den hat er ja schon bei Lazio, ist auch schon 35. Aber Asabi ist auch in den letzten Wochen einer, der mit am konstantesten da abliefert und die Verteidigung zusammenhält. Und wie du gesagt hast, ist dann... Man muss nicht alles irgendwie cool finden, was er macht, aber ich glaube, er ist einer, der da schon auch immer ein Faktor ist. Gerade in dem Sinne, was ich gesagt hatte, dass du halt als Gegenspieler auf ihn keinen Bock hast ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt.
Ja, und er war sehr früh in diesem Spiel. Und es war ein fantastisches Spiel, tolle Stimmung. Also da können wir uns auch aufs Rückspiel jetzt noch freuen. Das war einfach ein besonderer Abend. Besonders ist auch, dass Alexis Menuge hier in dieser Runde ist. Warum? Das habt ihr nicht gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber er hat uns schon mehrfach verlassen. Und deswegen will ich jetzt, Alexis, die Chance nutzen, wo du jetzt hier bist, dass wir nochmal mit dir über die Ligue 1 sprechen. Denn wir müssen ja auch noch über Olympique Lyon sprechen.
Olympique Lyon, da steht man vor der Revolution in diesem Sommer. Einer der traditionsreichen Vereine Frankreichs. Und jetzt ist diese Mannschaft oder dieser Verein von einem amerikanischen Investor übernommen worden, der schon mehrere Clubs hat. Der belgische Verein Molenbeek, Botafogo Brasilien und insbesondere auch Crystal Palace in der Premier League. Und jetzt hat er Lyon übernommen und hat sogar den französischen Uli Hoeneß, den hatte man schon als Thema bei Hasenfunk vor ein paar Wochen, rausgeschmissen. Jean-Michel Olaß, die Ikone oder der meistgehasste Chef eines Fußballprofi-Vereins in Frankreich. Er war jetzt insgesamt 36 Jahren an der Macht. Und bei diesem denkwürdigen Spiel am letzten Sonntag, Heimspiel gegen Montpellier, ich sage denkwürdig, weil es ging 5-4 aus, nach 1-4 Rückstand. Dabei hatten wir zwei Spieler, die einen Vierer-Pakt erzielt haben. Die kommen nicht alle Tage in der Liga 1, nicht mal in der Fantastischen Fußball-Bundesliga. Und bei diesem Spiel war Jean-Michel Olaß nicht mal im Stadion. Da hat man sich schon gefragt, was da los ist. Am nächsten Tag haben wir erfahren, dass John Texter, so heißt der neue Patron von Olympique Lyon, hat Jean-Michel Olaß die Ausgangstür gezeigt. Es gab schon Reibungen zwischen beiden in den letzten Wochen. Zwar sagt offiziell Texter Lyon, Olaß wird noch tief verbunden bleiben. Er wird eine besondere Loge haben im Stadion, für jedes Heimspiel, für seine gesamte Familie. Er wird auch sehr nah an die Frauenmannschaft sein. Aber das sind alles Babalapapp-Sätze, um einfach die Lage zu beruhigen. Aber man merkt schon, dass sich da anbandt, was bei Olaß Lyon für diesen Sommer zum vierten Mal in Folge, glaube ich, wenn man nicht an der Champions League teilnehmen. Aber Texter hat schon massive Investments im Kader oder für den künftigen Kader angedeutet. Das heißt auch, auch wenn er es nicht erwähnt hat, weil er komplett verschwunden ist, dass Jörg Boateng nicht verlängern wird, schon mal für uns zur Info. Aber man kann schon fest davon ausgehen, wenn die Liga wieder startet Mitte August, dass wir dann ein komplett neues Gesicht haben. Bei Olympique Lyon vielleicht einen neuen Trainer, Laurent Blanc, auch wenn er gerade bestätigt worden ist. Aber was heißt das schon? Bei amerikanischen Chefs, die von heute auf morgen sehr schnell umentscheiden können. Und auch der Sportdirektor, der Generalmanager und wie gesagt der Residenz sind so gut wie draußen. Und so wird man einen komplett neuen Verein haben im kommenden Sommer. Und dann müssen die Ergebnisse schnell geliefert werden, weil sonst die Fans sich dagegen wehren werden. Die haben viel Macht, haben wir auch gesehen, jetzt am Sonntag können sie auch viel Lärm machen, die Ultras und da steht dieser Verein, dieser besondere Verein in Frankreich, schon vor einer neuen Ära. So hofft man sich zumindest, um wieder national, aber auch mal international oben wieder mitspielen zu können.
Wie würdest du denn dann Jean-Michel Hollard einordnen bei Olympique? Also du hast schon unter anderem die Frauen erwähnt. Also er ist ein Freund des Frauenfußballs, unter anderem deswegen ist Olympique auch im Frauenfußball so erfolgreich geworden in den letzten Jahren. Aber du hast es ja auch schon durchklingen lassen, er ist auch sehr streitbar. Also ist ja klar, jemand, der mit Uli Hoeneß verglichen wird, der muss viele verschiedene Facetten in seiner Persönlichkeit haben. Was würdest du sagen, was muss man über ihn und diesen Rücktritt nach 36 Jahren wissen?
Also im Positiven muss man schon erwähnen, dass er aus Olympique Lune natürlich einen Verein gemacht hat, ohne externe Hilfe damals zu Nummer 1 in Frankreich gemacht hat. Siebenmal im Folgemeister, dass er nicht mal PSG mit seinen Milliarden geschaffen wird, auch nie schaffen. Dann, man war ja in der Champions League oft im Viertelfinale dabei. Und dann, du hast es erwähnt, die Frauenmannschaft. Er hat aus Olympik Jungen jahrelang die beste Mannschaft Europas geformt. Mehrfach Champions-League-Sieger geworden. Natürlich hat man jetzt ein bisschen mehr Probleme, aber auch da muss man erwähnen. Max, die Frauenabteilung ist auch da. Verkauft worden an eine amerikanische Frau, die da auch für die neue Saison ist. Das ist noch nicht offiziell, aber soll zum 30. Juni erfolgen. Also auch da, historisch betrachtet, wird eine neue Ära eingefügt bei der Frauenmannschaft. Und Olaß hat aber trotzdem einen sehr großen Anteil an diesen Erfolgen in den letzten Jahren gehabt, national wie auf dem europäischen Paket. Dazu muss man auch sagen, dass Olaß auch viel gemacht hat für die Konkurrenzfähigkeit des französischen Vereinsfußballes. Er war sehr investiert beim Liga-Verband und auch beim Verband. Er galt auch zuletzt als eventuellen Kandidaten für den Posten des neuen Verbandspräsidenten, was er schon abgelehnt hat, weil er auch weit über 70 und nicht jeder sein kann wie Noel LeGrette, wenn ihr weiß, was ich meine. Also schön über 80 weiterarbeiten, aber trotzdem nichts tun. Aus der Champagne um 13 Uhr schön auf den Tisch haben und danach nicht mehr erreichbar sein. Kann man zu. Auf der negativen Seite muss man sagen, du hast auch erwähnt, er hat enorm polarisiert. Schon vor den sozialen Medien, da hat er immer wieder schon Klarikante gezeigt, hat auch wie Uli Hoeneß in verschiedenen Sendungen im TV, im Radio live angerufen, obwohl es gar nicht geplant war, weil er sich beschweren wollte. Hat auch gewisse Journalisten gedroht, vor Justiz zu gehen und auch schon Schimpfwörter dabei benutzt, weil er einfach seinen Verein mit Rauch und Krach immer verteidigt hat, auch wenn es mal nicht so rund lief. Er hatte auch mal Probleme mit vielen großen oder namhaften Spielern, wie Giovane Elba damals, vor knapp 20 Jahren jetzt, wo Elba verletzt war und sich lieber von Magier Müller-Wolfhardt behandeln ließ, was da Olaß nicht gefiel. Und da gab es auch immer wieder Reibungen. Und trotzdem sagen schon die meisten heute Olaß, wie man vermisst, erstmal weil er polarisiert, weil er aber auch viel für den französischen Fußball getan hat, weil er eine Figur ist, viel Charisma hat und wer soll in diesem Sinne sein Nachfolger werden. Und im Gegensatz zu vielen europäischen Vereinsverantwortlichen und auch zu vielleicht einer, der ihn fast auf dem gleichen Niveau hat, weil er auch seine Mannschaft damals, oder sein Verein, den Olympique macht, sehr nach vorne gebracht hat, aber trotzdem dann im Gefängnis war, weil er auch grob schon entstanden war. Ich will von Bernhard Tapie reden. Im Gegensatz zu Tapie kann sich bisher Olaß nichts zu Schulden kommen lassen. Er war in keiner Affäre involviert und deswegen scheint er sauber zu sein. Und das ist auch nicht alle Tage der Fall. Das kann man ruhig erwähnen.
Also vielleicht eher Willy Lemke und nicht Uli Hoeneß? Ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, dich gerade beleidigt zu haben, obwohl ich das nicht wollte. Na gut, das würde jetzt zu weit führen. Aber wir sehen, da ändert eine Ära. Wir sehen auch die Auswirkungen der Investorisierung des Weltfußballs. Also nicht nur der Mighty Club Ownership ist wirklich ein riesen, riesen Thema. Die FIFA und die UEFA, also UEFA vor allem, muss das angehen, wird es aber nicht tun. Weil, nach allem, was man bisher so von ihm lesen konnte, finden die das nicht ganz so schlimm. Aber es ist wirklich erstaunlich, was sich da verändert. Und in der Bundesliga haben wir diese Diskussion so noch nicht. Wir haben halt, ich hab so das Gefühl, wir stehen quasi so auf der Vorstufe, weil wir noch über 50 plus 1 reden. Und wir haben jetzt mal einen DFL-Investor, den man sich reinholt, eventuell reinholt. Da fällt ja am 24. Mai die Entscheidung. Ich finde, genau hingucken bei solchen Sachen im Ausland und sich dann überlegen, will man das wirklich auch im heimischen Fußballbereich haben.
Zifferin ist gerade damit beschäftigt, dann zu gucken, wie viele Punkte er Juve abziehen muss, sodass sie nicht Champions League spielen.
Wobei ich ja schon gehört habe, das hast du doch bei 390 erzählt, dass das ja vielleicht schon der italienische Verband für ihn übernimmt, dass er es nicht machen muss.
Das ist auch wild. Da habe ich tatsächlich noch zwei Sachen. Eine, die mir vorhin bei Napoli durchgerutscht ist, die ich finde, die wirklich lustig ist, dass die hatten ja eh schon vier oder fünf Trikots in dieser Saison, inklusive Valentinstagstrikots etc. Bei der Meisterfeier hat der Präsident dem Trainer ein Trikot überreicht, wo so Konterfeier von Spalletti drauf waren und viele dachten, dass es irgendwie ein Unikat, das er für ihn hat drucken lassen. Mitnichten. Diese Trikots gibt es jetzt in 33-facher Ausführung. Jeder Kaderspieler hat ein eigenes Trikot. Das kann man pro Stück für 150 Euro erwerben. Spielberechtigt sind sie mit diesen Trikots nicht, aber man kann sich jetzt auch ein Trikot sozusagen mit Bildern von Diego Demme drauf kaufen. Oder dem dritten Ersatztorwart. Und vielleicht auch Juwe-Thema. Wobei, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es bei Juwe reinpasst, dass es auch wieder eine Schublade ist, die ich schnell aufmache. Aber vielleicht ein kleiner Cliffhanger. Das dürfen Marius oder Christian dann beim nächsten Mal besprechen. Es bahnt sich eventuell wieder ein kleiner Schiri-Skandal an in der Serie A. Da hat ein Linienrichter das Gespräch mit dem Schiedsrichterbeobachter nach einer Partie aufgenommen, der im Wortlaut gesagt hat, ich habe es viel in der Serie B und C beobachtet. Danke an die Freunde aus Turin und Rocky. Das ist der Schiri-Boss. Eventuell gibt es da Fetternwirtschaft auf Verbands-Ebene, aber wäre noch nie vorgekommen, glaube ich.
Ja, und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht die Schublade, welchen Landes du da gerade aufgemacht hast. Also das könnte auch sehr gut die deutsche Schublade sein. Fetternwirtschaft bei Schiedsrichtern, das kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen. Wer war noch mal am Armee? Na ja, googelt das, die jüngeren Hörerinnen und Hörer. Du musst nichts sagen. Sagen muss jetzt nur noch Alex etwas, denn wir wollen noch ein letztes Mal auf La Liga blicken. Wir haben ganz viel über Barca gesprochen, erstaunlich viel über Lionel Messi. Jetzt müssen wir, weil ansonsten sliden wir nämlich auch noch die Realfans in die DMs. Das kann ich jetzt nicht gebrauchen. Rest in peace, my inbox, das sage ich dazu nur. Also müssen wir jetzt natürlich über Real auch noch sprechen, Alex. Aber du hast ja auch gute Gründe dafür. Welche denn?
Ja, der erste Grund ist, sie sind frisch gebackener Pokalsieger, denn am letzten Wochenende ruhte ja La Liga, denn da war das Pokalfinale Copa del Rey Finale und Real Madrid hat die Copa gewonnen gegen Osasuna. Gegen das aufmüpfige, kleine, tapfere Osasuna. Aber eben für das Team aus Pamplona hat es nicht ganz gereicht. Der Underdog war eine sehr, sehr schöne Geschichte, der zum zweiten Mal überhaupt erst in einem Finale stand. Pokalfinale, der noch nie ein Pokal gewonnen hat. Also irgendein. Von daher waren da die meisten Herzen, glaube ich, der neutralen Fußballfans eher Osasuna zugetan. Aber Real hat das eben abgezockt gemacht, unter anderem mit einem sehr starken Vinicius, der zwar kein Tor geschossen hat, aber einfach da auf links eine Wucht war. Und wie stark der ist, konnte der ein oder andere geneigte Fußballfan dann auch am Dienstag sehen in der Champions League. Da war er auch nicht ganz so schlecht. Also Real Madrid ein Pokal gewonnen und vielleicht rauf und dran den zweiten, nämlich den weitaus größeren ja auch, zu gewinnen oder zumindest auf dem Weg zu sein in der Champions League da mal wieder ins Finale vorzustoßen. Also von daher aktuell Real Madrid ganz gut unterwegs, würde ich sagen.
Bevor wir über die Champions League sprechen, lass kurz bei dem Copa del Rey Finale bleiben. Ich habe eine unglaubliche Freude und Euphorie über diesen Titel gesehen, die mich als Banausen gewundert hat. Also war das etwas so besonderes für Real, diesen Pokal zu gewinnen?
Ich dachte kurz, das ist Ironie.
Ist das ernst?
Nee, das war ernsthaft. Aber dann bin ich vielleicht einfach nur nie das Kerne auf dem Leim gegangen, weil der hat sich extrem gefreut.
Okay, gut, dann war das bei ihm.
Könnte sein, könnte sein, weiß ich nicht. Ich hatte das Gefühl, es wird nicht ganz so zelebriert bei Real Madrid. Wie gesagt, nur ein sehr subjektives Empfinden, wie, keine Ahnung, wie in Eintracht Frankfurt das Ding in Deutschland gewinnen würde oder...
Okay, okay, da bin ich halt wirklich in meiner Timeline. Da waren noch so ein paar Frauenfußball-Journalistinnen mit dabei. Da gibt es auch eine, die ist quasi, die war auch früher mal Spielerin bei Real, die ist auch total ausgerastet. Aber gut, da hätte ich vielleicht mal ein bisschen meine Quellen hinterher fragen sollen.
Also einen Platzsturm gab es nicht im La Catucha, in Sevilla, im Finalstadion.
Gott sei Dank, denn sowas wollen wir nicht sehen, Alex. Das sind Bilder, die wir nicht sehen wollen.
Das wollen wir nicht sehen. Nee, gab es nicht. Es war eher gedämpft. Es ist halt doch nur der Pokal. Und vor allem für die großen Clubs, wobei so viele große in Spanien gibt es ja nicht. Da gibt es ja eigentlich nur zwei ganz, ganz große. Für die ist das halt meistens eher nur ein Trostpreis. Meistens, auch wenn es teilweise ja der einzige Pokal sein könnte. Aber ich glaube, die Stimmung wäre etwas weniger oder etwas euphorischer gewesen, hätte Ossasuna, wie gesagt, seinen ersten Titel gewonnen. Also nee, das war eher gedämpft, fand ich. Die Zeremonie, die Jubelbilder Real Madrids auch natürlich, weil einfach drei Tage später, vier Tage später, und jetzt können wir den Bogen spannen, Champions League gegen Man City anstand, und das einfach das größere Spiel für Real Madrid ist, ohne Win und Aber.
Also, ich konnte das Spiel leider nicht sehen. Ich habe allerdings in der Halbzeit...
Das ist ein Skandal.
Statistik gesehen, ja, ich weiß, es ist ein Skandal, aber ich bin ja hier und nur der Moderator. Ihr müsst ja die Antworten geben. Ich habe aber die Statistik der Halbzeit gesehen, und da hatte, glaube ich, City sechs Schüsse und Real Madrid einen, und Zwischenstand war eins zu null für Real. Wie war denn das Spiel dazu? Am Ende ist es ja ein eins zu eins geworden, weil Kevin de Bruyne noch den Ausgleich machen konnte.
Ja, aber solche Zahlen erzählen halt nicht immer die ganze Wahrheit. Da gehört halt viel, ja, viele Nuancen sind da dabei. Also ich persönlich fand, das war wirklich ganz, ganz hohes europäisches Niveau. Ich glaube, die anderen Jungs hier im Call geben mir da wahrscheinlich recht oder sind da meine Meinung. Das war wirklich, wie der Name schon sagt, City Real klingt ja eh nach einem vorgezogenen Finale, wenn wir ehrlich sind. So war fand ich das Spiel auch ganz, ganz hohes sportliches Niveau. Und dass Real Madrid in der Champions League abgezockt ist und dass sie nicht 80 Prozent Ballbesitz brauchen und 18 Torschüsse, um mal ein Tor zu machen, sondern eher aus sehr wenig, unfassbar viel machen können, weil sie unglaublich abgezockt sind, da erzähl ich niemandem was Neues. Von daher, City war fand ich besser im Spiel, hat einen guten Auswärtsauftritt hingelegt, wie ich fand, war sehr, sehr fokussiert, sehr konzentriert, anders als zum Beispiel in München, wo ich sie nicht gut fand. Ja, da hatten sie das 0-3 oder das 3-0 im Rücken aus dem Hinspiel, klar. Aber im Viertelfinale bei den Bayern fand ich City eher wackelig, ängstlich, zaghaft. Das war, fand ich jetzt anders im Bernabéu. Da haben sie eher mit dieser Selbstsicherheit, die sie ja sowieso eigentlich immer haben, zumindest in der Premier League, sind sie aufgetreten. Aber es ist nun mal Real Madrid. Da gibt es einmal eine Balleroberung, einmal einen Burst nach vorne von wem auch immer. Kann man winken auf Vinicius und er haut das Ding knallhart rein. Das ist einfach das ganz, ganz große europäisches Niveau, Real Madrid in der Champions League. Aber ich fand, City hat trotzdem sich gefangen und war ja nicht minder hässlich das Tor von de Bruyne. Das war auch ein ganz, ganz hohes Niveau, würde ich sagen.
Ich fand das Spiel nicht so positiv wie du. Alex, es war ein gutes Spiel, aber nicht so hervorragend, wie du sagst.
Na ja, es war kein 5-5 mit 37 großen Chancen.
Nein, wir brauchen keine 5-5, um zu sagen, es war ein gutes Spiel. Das war nicht bei dir, aber 1-1. Ansonsten haben wir, ohne das Tor von de Bruyne, der wirklich sensationell war, war de Bruyne nicht so gut in diesem Spiel. Haaland war nicht zu sehen, wie oft die Großen spielen, außer gegen Bayern. Und was mich ein bisschen skandalisiert hat, ist, dass zwei deutsche Nationalspieler hätten vom Platz fliegen müssen, nämlich die Herren Rüdiger und Kroos. Die haben nicht mal gelb gesehen, also Kroos nicht zumindest. Das darf auf diesem Niveau nicht passieren. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob da die UEFA wieder mit dabei war. Man braucht alle Top-Spieler im Rückspiel, obwohl Rüdiger nur gespielt hat, weil Militao gesperrt war, glaube ich. Aber was der mit seinem Ellenbogen gegen Gündogan macht, Frechheit und das Gleiche mit Kroos auch wieder gegen den armen Gündogan.
Arme Gündogan, von seinen Kollegen mal trittiert, na, Nationalmannschaftskollegen oder Ex-Kollegen bei Kroos.
Das scheint nicht so beliebt zu sein.
Er hatte auch seine Ausländer-Setzung mit Kimmich mehrfach. Und Goreska natürlich gegen Bayern für die Finale.
Man könnte sagen, Vorgeschmack auf nächste Saison, falls Gündogan beim FC Barcelona landet. Aber das kann man ja noch beobachten. Ob da etwaige Revalitäten dann auch weiter ausgelebt werden. Vielleicht war das nur ein Vorgeschmack für Herrn Gündogan. Mal sehen. Ja, das sah ich jetzt nicht ganz so eng. Auch die Rüdiger-Szene fand ich jetzt nicht so dramatisch, um ehrlich zu sein. Und an die Kroos-Szene erinnere ich mich nicht. Aber dass Toni Kroos gerne mal davon kommt. Der hat halt eine Aura, der Mann. In Spanien vor allem. Das wird eigentlich noch mal anders gesehen. Von daher verzeiht man ihm vielleicht gerne mal das eine oder andere Foul. Das ist schon okay so.
Ja, ganz kurz dazu. Ich habe schon auch das Gefühl, dass eine sehr großzügige Spieleitung angesetzt wird jetzt bei den letzten K.O.-Duellen auch in der Champions League.
Das ist ja nicht selten in der Champions League, Mario.
Genau, da sagt man so, der Schiri kriegt Sonnenbrand auf dem Handrücken. Somit immer ruhig, ruhig, wie der Mann. Mir hat der Schiri insgesamt nicht gefallen. Der war irgendwie so Verkehrspolizist. Sehr viel mit den Armen rumgewädelt und so.
Hat ein Deutscher gepfiffen?
Ich teile aber den Eindruck, ich hätte Real tatsächlich noch passiver eingeschätzt, aber dann eben mit diesen Nadelstichen. In der ersten Anfangsphase waren sie ja auch so unterwegs, aber haben dann auch tatsächlich bewiesen mit ein, zwei Situationen, wie schnell sie für Gefahr sorgen können. Was dann auch, glaube ich, muss man einfach mal, hört sich blatt an, aber das macht ja was im Kopf des Gegners. Ah, es ist real. Sie kommen einmal da und Benzema wäre zur Stelle. Und danach, teils in der zweiten Halbzeit, waren die ja auch wirklich irgendwie drauf und dran. Ich hatte das Gefühl, die wollen jetzt definitiv den Heimsieg und sind gar nicht so sehr zurückhaltend, wie ich sie erwartet hätte. Insgesamt glaube ich trotzdem, ja in der Summe, wenn du das Spiel in Gänze betrachtest, ist das 1-1 für real gar nicht das optimale Ergebnis. Da wäre mehr drin gewesen. Weil auch wenn Rüdiger sich da, Alexi hat schon zum Teil recht daneben genommen hat, der hat auch Harlan komplett in der Tasche gehabt. Das musst du auch da mal hervorheben. Ich war deswegen aber auch ehrlicherweise gestern über das Spiel in Mailand so erfreut, weil ich doch dann auch den Eindruck hatte, oder in den letzten Wochen Gesprächen mit Kollegen, dass es dann so bei Real abgezockt ist. Und die machen dann das, was sie können. Und ich dachte, wenn jetzt das Mailand Derby 0-0 ausgeht, dann ist wieder der deutsche Journalist dabei, das Wort Catenaccio in die Headline zu packen. Also das ist so zweierlei Maß. Und weil du einmal auch dieses schöne Konstrukt des vorgezogenen Finales benutzt hast, ich würde mich dann doch auch sehr freuen, wenn trotz aller Buchmacherquoten, und man wahrscheinlich dann eine 10er-Quote fürs Sieg von Inter oder Milan bekommt im Finale, würde ich mich sehr freuen, wenn die italienische Mannschaft dann mit Taktik wie Roberto Di Matteo, sorry Max, wie 2012 dann die Champions League gewinnen würde.
Traue ich Inter zu tatsächlich? Würde ich zutrauen?
Ich wäre auch hässlich, hässlich 1-0.
Ach du, Milan auch mit dem Torhüter.
Ich habe sie nämlich in Porto gesehen. Also ich war nicht in Porto, aber gegen Porto gesehen. Ich glaube, das ging ungefähr in die Richtung, oder? So ein 1-0 aller Roberto Di Matteo.
Genau, das können sie ja auch. Das ist, glaube ich, nicht die Grundherangehensweise, aber sie können es eben auch. Ich finde dann immer solche Spiele, und auch gerade bei Real ganz oft, so schön zu erkennen, dass halt so auch Fußball funktioniert.
Wie hat Real die letzte Champions League gewonnen? Das war auch nicht so prickelnd. Finale gegen Liverpool. Drei Courtois standen da im Tor, hatte man im Gefühl. Oder ein 3-Meter-Courtois.
Das ist jetzt aber wieder so eine Frage, die kann nur von einem deutschen Podcaster kommen. So darf man nicht auf dieses Finale blicken. Real ist ja auch... Ich habe einen Witz gemacht, das war auch nicht offensichtlich.
Das war ja nicht mal als Kritik gemeint. Das war nur eine Feststellung, dass es verschiedene Wege gibt, Fußballspiele zu gewinnen. Manchmal brauchst du eine gute Abwehr, manchmal einen guten Torwart, manchmal beides. Manchmal einen abgezockten Stürmer oder Flügelspieler. Optimal hast du alles, und dann gewinnst du ein großes Spiel. Keine Kritik ans weiße Lager oder an Herrn Groß.
Genau, ich wollte auch nur einen Witz machen. Aber ich finde, an Teams wie Real, da siehst du nicht nur, was feste Achsen bewirken. Ich meine, schau dir Groß und Modric in diesem Mittelfeld an. Das ist halt einfach absurd, welche Ruhe die ausstrahlen. Aber das ist auch etwas, was im Leistungssport oft unterschätzt wird. Die Ruhe, während du einen Puls von 200 hast und das Adrenalin schon reinkickt und alle nur auf dich gucken, das macht dann tatsächlich den Unterschied. Dann gibt es Teams, die vergeben Chance um Chance um Chance und werden eigentlich auch immer aufgeregter. Das ist sogar schon City passiert, obwohl die eigentlich aus Ruhe heraus, also die ganze Fußballphilosophie von Pep Guardiola, beruht ja auf Kontrolle, um eben quasi systematisch sich Chancen zu erziehen. Und du brauchst aber manchmal, in manchen Spielen, brauchst du einfach nur die Ruhe vorm Tor. Die zum Beispiel auch Milan nicht hatte gegen Inter, in den wenigen Situationen, die zu Chancen hätten werden können. So stimmt es eigentlich. Da waren die auch fürchterlich aufgedreht. Und Real ist halt einfach der große Junge, der angeblich in der U15 noch spielen darf. Er wirkt aber viel größer und erwachsener. Und der zockt das halt einfach in Ruhe aus. Und der lässt sich halt einfach nicht zur Seite schubsen. Und der lässt sich auch nicht verunsicher von einem Rückstand. Und das ist halt eine Qualität, die ist halt schwer in Statistiken zu messen. Aber vielleicht viel wichtiger als so manch anderes.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was ich vorhin auch meinte, mit überfordert bei Milan. Also war dann, wir sind in der Nähe vom Strafraum. Jetzt oder nie? Und die sind jetzt leider sehr weit davon entfernt. Aber es wäre natürlich auch irgendwie, ich habe dann ein Interview bei, ich glaube Reihe Uno mit Carlo Angelotti am Dienstag gesehen nach dem Spiel. Wir sind dann auch nach dem Derby, aufs Derby ansprechen und er sagt, certo, uno, due, forza Milan. Wenn Angelotti dann da gegen Milan das Finale spielen würde, das hätte schon auch natürlich was. Solche Geschichten schreibt nur der Fußball.
Aber wirklich, ausschließlich der Fußball. Wir werden es ja hier beobachten, denn wir werden tatsächlich nach dem Champions League Finale noch eine Ligatur aufnehmen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wir kommen nicht dran vorbei. Ich habe jetzt diese Regelmäßigkeit hier gestartet. Ich habe mich so sehr an euch gewöhnt. Das muss jetzt einfach sein. Wann genau und so weiter, das kriegt ihr dann alles mit. Bis dahin wird ja auch noch ein Rasenfunk-Royal aufgenommen, unter anderem. Aber da werden wir unter anderem über dieses 1-0 von Milan gegen Real im Finale dann sprechen können. Oder wie auch immer es werden wird. Jetzt aber sind wir tatsächlich am Ende angekommen. Ich danke euch sehr. Das war eine unheimlich interessante Runde. Es hat mir große Freude gemacht. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Mario Rieker, den Ed Remedem auf Twitter. Danke dir, lieber Mario. Hört alle Serie am Ohre. Und hört natürlich auch Tiki Taka, den Podcast, bei dem Alex Truica mit dabei ist, der so auch auf Twitter unterwegs ist. Danke dir, lieber Alex.
Sehr gerne, danke es ebenfalls.
Und bei Alexis Menuge kann es noch eine Frage der Zeit sein, bis er auch seinen eigenen Podcast hat. Ich habe ihn jetzt auch im Nachholspiel-Podcast gehört. Sehr schöne Folge, Alexi. Schön, dass du hier warst und sag uns halt Bescheid, wenn du dann dein eigenes Projekt gestartet hast. Das ist ein Bummer zum Schluss, aber gut. Wenigstens geht es mit einem Highlight weiter. Hier hört ihr jetzt gleich Uli Hebel. Jetzt bei mir ist Uli Hebel. Hallo Uli, schön, dass du Zeit für den Rasenfunk hast.
Immer sehr gerne, grüß dich.
Grüße dich auch, wir wollen sprechen über die Premier League. Und da hatten wir einen fantastischen Feiertagsspieltag, der ja nur stattgefunden hat wegen der Krönung von King's Stars. Hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Es ist ein Bank Holiday Monday, die gibt es immer mal wieder so verstreut in England. Ich kann dir aber gar nicht genau sagen, da haben wir intern auch immer diskutiert. Ist das so oder ist das nicht so? Ich glaube, die gibt es öfter mal. Aber mich würde es auch nicht wundern, wenn es nur deshalb war.
Dann hätte diese Gründung wenigstens eine gute Sache gehabt, nämlich fantastische Spiele. Ich lese einfach nur die Ergebnisse vor und du darfst mir dann alles sagen, was ich dazu wissen muss. Fulham gegen Leicester 5 zu 3, Brighton gegen Everton 1 zu 5, Nottingham Forest gegen Southampton 4 zu 3. Da war was los.
Ja, da war echt richtig was los. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich jemals an einem Tag so viel Spektakel erlebt habe. Und was ja alle drei Spiele eint, ist, dass bei allen drei Spielen, bei einem sogar zwei, absoluter Abstiegskampf ausgerufen war. Und es darum ging, dass Big Points gemacht werden können oder vielleicht sogar müssen in einigen Fällen. Also Nottingham Forest gegen Southampton. Das letzte dann an diesem Montag. Das ist ein absolutes Endspiel gewesen für Southampton, weil die eh schon den Anschluss verpasst haben. Und uns einklar war, würden die jetzt nicht gegen Nottingham gewinnen. Eines der noch schwächeren Teams im verbleibenden Abstiegskampf. Dann wird es nichts für die. Und genauso kam es dann, dass die am Ende 4-3 verlieren. Das war jetzt noch vom Verlauf her eines der, ich sage jetzt mal normaleren Spiele, auch wenn es Southampton auch daran kam.
Das wundert mich, weil ich habe nur gesehen, 19 zu 9 Schüsse für Southampton, Ergebnis 3 zu 4. Da dachte ich mir, okay, das lief irgendwie nicht so.
Nee, das ist aber eigentlich in den letzten Wochen oft so. Das Southampton gar nicht so schlechte Leistungen bringt. Aber es reißt halt im Verlauf der 90 Minuten immer ab. Aber so wie es lief, dass Northampton im Forest 3 1 führte, dann kommt Southampton noch mal einigermaßen normal ran. Also im ersten Spiel z.B. Fulham gegen Leicester, da war ja Fulham schon mit 3-0 davon. Und dann machen sie es noch mal spannend. Wobei das das Team ist, muss man auch ehrlich sagen, Fulham, die sind ja eigentlich im Urlaub, weil da geht es nach oben um nichts mehr, nach unten um nichts mehr. Deswegen kann sowas da vielleicht noch mal vorkommen. Aber die haben jetzt auch nicht die Sterne vom Himmel gespielt in den letzten Wochen. Und Brighton gegen Everton ist aus dem Grund krass, weil Everton... Also, ich sage es jetzt mal, wie es ist, die Saison ist fürchterlich. Und die letzten Jahre sind fürchterlich. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich jemals so eine fußballerische Leistung Evertons gesehen hätte. Das war jetzt auch nicht so, dass die den wunderschönsten Kombinationsfußball gespielt hätten. Nur haben die, das war wirklich eine Sean Deitch Masterclass, die haben einfach alles darauf angelegt, dass sie im Konter Brighton im 1 gegen 1 schlagen. Das war gar kein Restverteidigungsthema bei Brighton oder so oder irgendwas, sondern das war einfach nur, sie haben es hinten darauf angelegt, dass sie in die Duelle kommen im Umschalten und die hat Everton im ersten Durchgang sang- und klanglos gewonnen und hat damit Brighton wirklich fast weggespült aus dem Stadion. Und Brighton wiederum spielt ja um die europäischen Plätze, weswegen das umso erstaunlicher ist, dass Everton ein Team, das sieben Mal in Folge nicht gewonnen hatte, dann plötzlich so eine Leistung hat. Was aber wieder zeigt, es ginge ja im Grunde bei Everton, wenn sie wollten.
Ja, wenn vielleicht auch der Spielverlauf passt. Ich meine, es hilft natürlich, wenn du in der ersten Minute schon mit 1 zu 0 in Führung gehst, auswärts, und dann deine Kontertaktik quasi sich auch manifestiert, weil dann muss der Gegner auch kommen. Also Brighton hätte gar keine andere Wahl gehabt. Wie sieht denn die Situation, wenn wir mal kurz beim Abstiegskampf bleiben, und da können wir vielleicht noch drüber reden, über Europa, was du ja auch schon gerade so ein bisschen mit angesprochen hast. Also Southampton ist jetzt so gut wie weg. Die haben 8 Punkte Rückstand auf das rettende Ufer. Wir haben den 35. Spieltag also nur noch 9 Punkte zu vergeben. Die nehmen wir raus. Dann Leeds, Leicester sind aktuell Vorletzter und Vorvorletzter mit 30 Punkten. 2 Punkte Abstand sind es zu erwarten. Da kann also ja doch noch was gehen. Und wir haben ja gerade bei Leeds auch wieder ein bisschen Veränderung.
Ja, also Leeds hat jetzt, das ist der denkbar dämlichste Zeitpunkt für einen Trainerwechsel, den man sich vorstellen kann. Für alle, die es nicht mitbekommen haben, da hat ja Jesse March gearbeitet, dann ist Javi Gracia für ein paar Wochen installiert worden. Ich glaube, das haben wir hier auch mal ganz kurz angedeutet, wenn ich mich komplett täusche. Gracia hat probiert, wie der SC Freiburg zu spielen in der Premier League mit einem Kader, der aufgebaut ist auf absolutes Hauruck. Entsprechend hat das solala funktioniert. Ich habe mir das schon gedacht, dass es in die Richtung gehen könnte, habe aber irgendwie auch verstanden, worum es geht. Und dann hat Leeds jetzt noch einmal vor dem Manchester City Spiel wohlgemerkt, alles abgeschnitten, was so da war. Das heißt, nicht nur den Trainer Javi Gracia, sondern auch Viktor Orta, den Sportdirektor, den ich nach wie vor für einen wahnsinnig fähigen Mann halte, weil der äußerst gut vernetzt ist, ein gutes Auge für Spieler hat und auch die Verpflichtungen von denen hinbekommt. Man kann jetzt darüber streiten, ob alles richtig war in der ganzen Amtszeit Jesse Marsch. Da haben sie den Kader extrem umgebaut. Ich finde nicht, dass vieles richtig war, von den Einzelspielern her. Ich glaube aber auch, dass das das war, was Jesse Marsch wollte. Und er hat ihm diesen Kader hingegeben. Jetzt hat Orta sich für Gracia entschieden, und das war jetzt wohl der Besitzerschaft eins zu viel. Man muss auch dabei wissen, bei Leeds ist das jetzt nicht normale Besitzerschaft, sondern da wabert jetzt schon seit eineinhalb Jahren die 49ers Group, also von den San Francisco 49ers, die Besitzerschaft, die da schon Minderheiten hat und an sich nur noch darauf wartet, die Mehrheiten übernehmen zu können. Woran es da ganz genau hakt, weiß niemand. Aber das wird irgendwann kommen, entsprechend haben die auch schon ein ganz schön gewichtiges Wörtchen, damit zu sprechen. Und aus Angst vor dem Abstieg, ich glaube, das ist ein ziemlich klarer Panikknopf-Move, hat man jetzt da nochmal gesagt, okay, egal, alles auf eine Karte und die heißt Sam Allardyce tatsächlich. Und mit Sam Allardyce gehst du ins erste Spiel gegen Manchester City und überraschungsgemäß verlierst du und hast jetzt deine Ausgangslage auch nicht zwingend verbessert. Naja.
Was muss ich denn zu Sam Allardyce wissen? Ist es ungerecht, wenn ich sage, der Peter Neurora der Premier League?
Nö, eigentlich nicht. Also das Ding ist, bis West Bromwich Albion vor ein paar Jahren, da war er auch eigentlich schon im Ruhestand und kam zurück, hat er zumindest diese Feuerwehrmann-Sam-Aufgaben immer gut gelöst. Jetzt hat er den Zauber aber auch verloren. Oder ansonsten ist Sam Allardyce Click and Rush. Kick and Rush, Entschuldigung. Das ist so Automatismus. Und das war's. Ehrlich gesagt, es scheint jemand zu sein, der eine sehr einfache Idee von Fußball hat. Mir hat Jan Kirchhoff das mal ganz ausführlich erzählt, dass das schon jemand ist, der einen positiven Einfluss auf Spieler hat, der eine gute Ausstrahlung hat, weil er jedem Spieler exakt eine Aufgabe mitgibt, die schleift er denen ein. Und die müssen sie dann umsetzen. Und das war's auch schon. Und damit fühlen sich aber Spieler durchaus wohl, weil es halt nicht mehr kompliziert ist. Nur, wir haben jetzt auch 2023 und nicht wie damals bei Jan Kirchhoff. Und da war es schon antiquiert, 2015 oder so. Sodass ich irgendwie sehr, sehr starke Zweifel an einem Wechsel habe, der jetzt auch Lizia binnen 14 Monaten von Marcelo Bielsa auf Sam Allardyce bringt. Also ich glaube, das ist allen klar, das wird schwierig, dass das was wird. Jetzt sind sie aber immer noch in Reichweite. Das ist klar. Also die sind immer noch in der Nähe der Nicht-Abstiegsplätze.
Ja gut, und sie haben halt zwei Heimspiele noch gegen Newcastle und gegen Tottenham. Natürlich auch gute Gegner. Und dann das Auswärtsspiel gegen West Ham, die im Grunde ja fast raus sind. Die werden bis dahin wahrscheinlich raus sein aus dem Abstiegskampf. Also vom Spielplan her könnte da noch was gehen für Liz.
Ja, ich habe die zwei Heimspiele echt kompliziert, weil für beide Tottenham und Newcastle geht es ja noch sogar um die Champions League. In der Theorie bei Tottenham nenne ich es nur die Champions League. Und West Ham ist raus. Die haben jetzt gegen United gewonnen. Also zum zweiten Mal in Folge wirklich gepunktet. Das heißt, die habe ich auch raus. Und das wissen wir auch seit den Wochenende. Crystal Palace und die Wolves sind rechnerisch auch durch.
Das heißt, dann haben wir noch Lester, Everton und Nottingham realistischerweise, die sich eben alle in so einem Drei-Punkte-Korridor da unten drin bewegen. Was ist zu denen noch zu sagen?
Also Lester hat auch noch mal einen Trainer gewechselt, Dean Smith. Ich finde, dass das eigentlich ganz gut aussieht. Das Problem bei denen ist, es scheint eine total verunsicherte Mannschaft zu sein. Anders kriege ich es nicht mehr erklärt, weil es strukturell inzwischen okay aussieht. Tats ja auch teilweise bei Brendan Rodgers. Und ich glaube, wenn das nicht klappt für Lester, dann muss man irgendwann mal über die Transferpolitik sprechen, dass sie einfach Abgänge nicht ersetzt haben und auch noch nicht mal im Winter, wo man schon wusste, dass es jetzt auf eine ganz, ganz komplizierte Phase zuläuft, dass sie da nicht wenigstens ein oder zwei Transfers gemacht haben. Ein komischer Kader, der eine komische Unwucht hat. Da sind einzelne richtig starke Ausnahmespieler wie Madison zum Beispiel dabei. Und dann gibt es Positionen, die sind durchschnittlich besetzt. Und das reicht einfach heutzutage nicht mehr. Bei Everton habe ich schon mal kurz gesagt, bei Everton gibt es einen Cheatcode im Abstiegskampf, wenn der gesund bleibt. Und das wahre jetzt mal vier Spiele in Folge ist Dominic Herbert-Luin, der alleine den Konterfußball möglich macht, den Everton spielt, weil er sich wirklich gegen jeden einzelnen Innenverteidiger der Liga durchsetzen kann, plus wahnsinnig schnell ist. Das heißt, wenn der drauf ist, kann man auch die langen Bälle spielen, umschalten, zweite Bälle, das ganze Standardprogramm, das ist dann möglich. Plus Everton hat sich auch noch mal ein bisschen verändert, sind jetzt im Pressing etwas, zumindest situativ, etwas aggressiver. Bisschen riskanter, also wirklich nur, soweit man das unter Sean Deisch sagen kann, ein bisschen riskanter geworden. Und das hilft aber schon, tut ganz gut. Und die haben dann auch nochmal Spiele drin, wo man denken könnte, ja, kann was werden. Bei Nottingham, das ist ehrlich gesagt für mich so, ich werde überhaupt nicht schlau aus denen. Einerseits mag ich Steve Kupas, ganz abwartendes Spieler, die spielen ganz oft ein 4-5-1 gegen den Ball. Und total passiv, aber dafür kompakt. Heißt aber, dass nach vorne selten was geht. Und immer, wenn ich das erzähle, hauen sie ein Viertore-Spiel raus. Wie jetzt am Bank Holiday Monday. Und das sind natürlich wichtige Punkte. Nichtsdestotrotz, also für mich ist es so, es ist weg. Bei Leeds mache ich mir große Sorgen. Und Nottingham glaube ich irgendwie an dir auch nicht.
Okay, das ist doch mal eine konkrete Vorhersage. Und gleichzeitig, wir haben es jetzt nicht bei jedem erwähnt, aber Leicester z.B. schüttet auch noch gegen Liverpool und gegen Newcastle, erwarten jetzt dann gegen City, Nottingham noch gegen Arsenal. Gleichzeitig werden diese Spiele im Keller auch das Rennen um Europa, Titelkampf will ich jetzt nicht aufrufen, ehrlich gesagt ausrufen, aber auch den Kampf um die Champions League noch beeinflussen. Und da hat sich ja auch ein bisschen was gedreht. Du hast es vorhin schon angesprochen. Brighton jetzt mit dem Rückschlag, die haben zwei Punkte Rückstand aktuell. Auf Tottenham, die liegen auf Rang 6. Liverpool auf Rang 5, haben aber den Anschluss an die Champions League-Plätze. Das haben wir hier in der Liga Tour noch nicht so wirklich aufgenommen. Manchester United, ein Punkt nur vor Liverpool. Newcastle ist drei Punkte vor Liverpool. Und dann kommen halt die großen zwei Arsenal und City, also die großen zwei dieser Saison. Wie sieht die Lage im oberen Segment aus? Wem gibst du da die besten Chancen?
Also ich fange jetzt mal von oben an, von Platz 3. Ich glaube, da gibt es ja noch ein leichtes Rennen drum. Inzwischen tatsächlich Liverpool wieder, erstaunlicherweise. Newcastle und Manchester United. Ich bin immer noch so, also zum einen hat zwar jetzt Newcastle verloren gegen Arsenal, hat aber eine ganz ordentliche Leistung gezeigt. Für mich ist das das Stabilste all der genannten Teams. Ja, Liverpool in den letzten Spielen ist stabiler und nach einem leichten Systemumbau spielen jetzt auch diese klassische 3-2-5-Struktur, die wahnsinnig gut zum Kader passt und auf einmal zwei, drei Problemchen löst. Tryter Alexander-Arnold kann mehr in die Mitte gehen, kann damit z.B. erstens seine defensive Schwäche kaschieren, weil er natürlich dann schon bei Ballverlust etwas kompakter steht, wenn er als sozusagen inverser Flügelverteidiger spielt. Auf der anderen Seite hast du Mohamed Salah, der jetzt mal wieder Diagonalbälle nehmen kann, die volle Breite für sich ausnutzen kann und endlich wieder mal den Ball am Fuß haben kann. Das hat er ja vorher eine ganze Zeit lang nicht, weil sie Hauruck gespielt haben im Umschalten plus. Jemand wie Curtis Jones z.B. kommt raus. Großes Problem bei Liverpool nach wie vor die Mittelfeldregionen gewesen. Und wenn er mit so einem 4-3-3-Mittelfeld spielt, dann kommen so ein dynamischer Achter wie Curtis Jones z.B. nicht so zum Tragen, der macht gerade einen Riesensprung. Das sind so die Gründe, warum es bei Liverpool gerade wieder richtig gut läuft. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt das Momentum sieht, ist Liverpool vielleicht das stabilste Team. Wenn man die ganze Saison sieht, ist Newcastle stark. Und ich habe immer gedacht, dass die nirgendwo hingehen. Auch in der kurzen Phase rund ums EFL Cup, das erste Pokalfinale. Ich glaube im Februar gab es mal eine schwächere Phase, ergebnistechnisch. Ich glaube aber, dass Newcastle die 3 macht. Und dann würde es nach meiner Metrik einen Rang-4-Kampf geben. Und das ist jetzt die Frage, bin ich jetzt vom Momentum so beeindruckt, weil United jetzt zwei Mal Folge 0-1 verliert. Und nach wie vor die alten Probleme hat, dass es eben mal Phasen gibt, wo es einfach nicht funktioniert. Auch mit David de Gea glaube ich einen Minus haben in diesem Kampf um Platz 4. Und weil Liverpool eben gerade gut aussieht. Und jetzt kommt das zum Tragen, was ich immer die ganze Saison über gedacht habe. Ja, es gibt ein paar Probleme bei Liverpool, aber ich habe immer geglaubt, sie sind einen Transfer oder eine Umstellung davon entfernt. Wir haben ja hier auch mal darüber gesprochen, dass ich immer das Gefühl hatte, ich glaube, ich muss denen jetzt was anderes geben, was die sicherer werden lässt. Hat er gemacht. Und wenn man vorher schimpft, muss man jetzt auch loben. Ich glaube fast sogar, dass Liverpool das noch packt.
Das sieht doch positiv aus. Und das würde ja auch bedeuten, dass Jörg Schmadtke dann als neuer Sportdirektor mit der Champions League planen kann. Kannst du mir dazu irgendwas sagen? Ich habe das einfach nur gelesen. Schmadtke zu Liverpool. Ich habe gecheckt, ob es der Postellon war. War es nicht. Und mehr weiß ich darüber nicht. Weiß man denn auch als Kenner schon mehr über dieses Gerücht?
Also tatsächlich kann ich auch nicht wirklich viel dazu sagen. Mich hat das absolut kalt erwischt, wie jeden Einzelnen oder jeder Einzelne wahrscheinlich zu Hause. Ich glaube, ich habe es am Samstagabend gelesen und hatte da noch einen Boxkampf vorzubereiten und war schon total müde und habe gedacht, okay, bei Twitter gibt es ja keine blauen Haken mehr. Ich habe vielleicht einfach nur die Quelle nicht richtig eingeschätzt. Und dann kamen logischerweise auch ein paar Fragen gleich. Hast du das gehört oder kannst du das sagen? Also ich wusste auch nicht mal genau, wo ich jetzt da ansetzen soll. Außer bei Matt Law selber vom Telegraph, der das ja rausgebracht hat. Und recht viel klüger bin ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht. Also alles, was man weiß, ist, die sprechen. Mir war auch neu, dass Klopp und Schmadtke befreundet sind. Gut, jetzt kennt man nicht jede Freundschaft im Fußballbusiness, aber ich würde mal tippen, das ist jetzt einfach so der Reim, den ich mir draufmache, dass Liverpool ja einen neuen Sportdirektor braucht, weil erstes Jahr Michael Edwards gegangen, vor einem Jahr, dann ist Julian Ward aufgerückt vom technischen Direktor zum Sportdirektor. Der will jetzt aber mal eine Pause vom Fußballgeschäft haben und jetzt musste Liverpool relativ schnell überlegen, ok, wen nehmen wir, vielleicht auch tatsächlich nur zu Überbrückungszwecken. Und da kam jetzt eben diese Personalie Schmadtke. Das heißt für mich zum einen, dass wahrscheinlich mal Klopp gefragt worden ist, wen könntest du dir vorstellen? Es gibt ja auch die Möglichkeit, dass Schmadtke das als eine Art freie Mitarbeiterverein macht und nur in beratender Funktion tätig sein könnte. Das ist das eine. Und zum anderen heißt das aber für mich auch. Und das ist für mich vielleicht fast sogar die interessantere Auswirkung dann jetzt, zumindest dieser Anfrage mal, dass Jürgen Klopp nicht plant, irgendwo hinzugehen. Gab es ja durchaus Spekulationen in der Zeit, als es nicht so gut lief. Aber ich würde tippen, dass das bedeutet, ne, der hat vor dann noch drei, vier Jahre zu bleiben. Und Schmadtke kann dann, ich glaube immer noch, nur zu Übergangszwecken helfen. Ich finde das nach wie vor wild. Also es ist viel, viel Komisches passiert in dieser Fußball-Saison finde ich. Auch gerade in England. Roy Hodgson zurück, Sam Allardyce übernimmt nur als Beispiel. Oder Frank Lampert zu Chelsea, wo ich echt gedacht habe, okay, jetzt haben sie alle ihren Verstand verloren. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass Schmadtke schlechte Arbeit macht. Ich kriege es einfach nie zusammen. Schmadtke und Liverpool. Nicht in 180.000 Jahren wäre ich da drauf gekommen. Wir hätten jetzt eine 50er-Liste machen können. Und den wäre da nicht drin gelandet.
Ja, gut. Dann gucken wir uns das an. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein bemerkenswertes Gerücht. Deswegen konnte ich es nicht ohne uns angesprochen lassen. Aber wir werden es ja sehen. Uli, ich danke dir ganz herzlich. Das war kurz und knackig, aber sehr, sehr meinungsfreudig. Und ich glaube, man kann sich auf den Saisonendsport in der Premier League wirklich freuen. So hört es sich zumindest an.
Das ist eine der spannendsten Konstellationen der letzten Jahre. Zumal ja oben auch noch nicht alles. Ich bin schon auch bei dir. Das muss man jetzt nicht klein diskutieren. Aber es ist nicht vorbei. Und wenn Everton noch mal so eine Leistung wie gegen Brighton bringt, dann wünsche ich mir auch viel Spaß bei City.
Das wird nämlich das nächste Auswärtsspiel von City sein. Wir gucken es uns an. Und man kann dann bei Click & Rush natürlich in deinem Podcast zusammen mit deinem Bruder Jogi Hebel das alles ganz genau nachhören. Danke dir, lieber Uli, für deine Zeit. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war eine lange Ligatur. Ich werde den Link zu dem Tweet, den Mario vorhin angesprochen hat, den werde ich in die Shownotes packen, wenn euch das interessiert. Und ansonsten hören wir uns hier wieder an dieser Stelle in der nächsten Woche. Da geht es dann um die Frauenbundesliga und um die zweite Männerbundesliga. Aber es gibt ja viel zu hören beim Rasenfunk. Es ist auch ein Tribüngespräch rausgekommen, was ich euch sehr empfehlen möchte. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund, bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, ciao!